all right and we are laughs welcome to
the Isle or podcast and the Lord's a
gaming dotnet episode number 115 it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got CD Projekt RED developer
ranking cyberpunk 2077 controversies end
of III rest in peace Lockhart and
destiny free to play to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
I want to introduce two Lords who I had
the pleasure of crossing password
through Lord Enrique of debasement radio
arcade podcast and Lady Luka of the scum
cast not only these two Lords true
friends the ILP and extremely
knowledgeable in the realm of gaming but
their combined passion for looter
shooters is always welcomed at the round
table
introducing first the creator of the
gaming for teh YouTube channel and
panelist of both the scum cast and rap
podcasts the most nautical one himself
and legend of the destiny grind and
introducing next the owner of the most
hilarious avatar on social media and
also apparent list of the scope cast and
Brad podcast the Lord of IT networking
and master of Division gear sets the
Crimson Guard brothers tome acts as a
bot of Gaelic live from the DMV and
Michigan and both making their debut
into the realm of the Lords
Mommy's Lords gaming forte and slo-mo
backslap how are you both doing sir man
that's what I'm talking about yeah we
did a joint boom did a good intro but
now boom boom gotta step your game up
man yes look I need was like Oh boom
boom tried to intro okay
let me take the cake okay Paul for a
second let me let me hear the toby is
like what again we'll get it to your
history but I had to call you on that
because I've know when I first came
across y'all it was like yah wait but
yeah on the same wavelength but you I do
something to Bob all the time I love you
I love that dynamic you guys have but
ultimately you do have the same goal so
let me tell you man when slow-mo was out
of town when he was putting his feet up
on a beach somewhere I was lost for a
week bro nah man let me tell you
something man City man the only thing
that could be better than being here
today with you guys it's affected by man
slow-mo here with me I give that man so
much crap every day every week we talk
man that's that's my man I love that man
today I got to bring back up to the park
well I don't know man depend on some of
these topics man you know some old I
think I think I need Oh has something up
his sleeve with a couple of these no no
you did some research on you did these
topics on my man yeah no but but
honestly man the fact that been a Sunday
yes I'm always on the other side
listening to this when I'm at work man
I'd make sure I took half a day at work
to make sure I was here for this cuz I
mean I slo-moes here with me and if you
ain't in church right now you should be
right here listening to this the number
one podcast Sunday morning is nothing I
don't care about any other platform on
Sundays
what you want to listen to out to the
Lord's man I'm so happy to be here with
you guys man much love brother I mean
really appreciate you guys the support
you know you guys have been rocking with
us for so long and like I was telling I
spoke to King an addict like I'm on a
mission besides like we like the big
names and all that stuff but I like the
people in the community the people are
people you're saying that really support
us and we want to give back to you guys
cuz you give to us you guys give us
energy in that chat every Sunday and
yeah like Slovo be late I'll be I'll be
looking forward say you be there start
even though the last verse out there but
like I'll be in there like so just I had
to give back you know say so salute it
slow mode you doing good brother man I'm
doing great man
yeah I like like I mean everything for
take you said this probably gonna be the
one thing that we will 100% agree on
today is that this is the fire podcast
like this is like one of my top 3
podcast I listened to one of the weekly
basis I made sure even if like I'm busy
on the Sunday you know how it is with
kids and a family you know it's like you
want to be able to listen some laugh and
this stuff pop up like you know what I'm
still gonna make sure I get that replay
though but love you already know so you
know we have normally we had four
horsemen we're a horsemen down so salut
saw you take care of business with the
fam arrow to the knee they took an arrow
to the lead they understand us smashed
his kneecaps
oh yeah king of her giving people
replacement surgery salute the Lord
denzel himself next sunday would get him
in track but we still got the other
horsemen of gaming my co-host with the
core most my brother from another mother
the difficult game khakhra and the heart
of the young both my man with that
breathtaking vid lord addict i doing sir
doing pretty good and my breathtaking
beer
tell them got a bit of brothers there
hit it big brother don't worry
make a podcast a long time ago got the
beer to be a lot of things you know our
deck but you know just now you just came
around with the camera so I'm looks like
okay now we could tell we know we got a
visually see you know people could be
like a frog magnet you gotta be my man's
got step it was good oh man what you
been playing man a lot of Final Fantasy
seven driver fraud he wants me to play
the yeah how's our destiny you know what
it is I got too much new stuff to be
going back digging into crates tears I
see you in you where you supposed to be
in the basement you know justice ever
sir yeah I have been playing a little
bit of that um good man what's it that
game called that we're really excited
for in the switch but I didn't play my
pager
no it's RPG that oh oh
Xenoblade Chronicles no it's like I
don't have to look it's a [ __ ] geo
RTS it's an RPG little tedious mutton my
switch isn't around here it's a game
pass batters night-night war
no I already beat that for the Xbox so
long switch I'm happy that's good I mean
that's what happens when you decide
chick don't know oh my god the old man
said he was on whole lot to go on there
he literally googled games that are on
game
like didn't King would you like to pay
the bill sir organ above home be
reminded that King Oh soft knees
the we can solve to try and retain them
salute the Lord hit that like your ship
changed still in the building grab you
knees the XS game ooh the Lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement Oh beloved Lord King how
you doing sir I'm doing terrible Oh
today I came in from work and one of my
jokes collapsed mmm they had a Batman
and Wonder Woman on it if I can go back
and look at those characters those
statues Oh
deceased at the moment man is still here
because I came and I said all right oh
you know what um take Aquaman put him on
the DC shelf and set that up and when I
want to well as I've gone inside the
room for Wonder Woman helped me like in
the womb Oh so I look in the corner
Batman and Wonder Woman is just boom
collapse like the DCE you
the marble statues was like we had
enough y'all to be really outnumbered
over there now but I saw some sway in
the in the shelving yeah saying how can
i reinforce it and stuff like that
during the week and I should have just
removed them I didn't give a whole
tutorial on that later but yeah that's
$900 out the window just boom just like
that no you gotta be careful on how you
shelving your stuff so if you see any
sway in your shelves make sure you fix
that mm it was supposed to be a fight
yesterday and Jamel charla was supposed
to fight Tony Harrison which would have
been a great combat talk but Tony
Harrison injured his foot hmm
fighting today
for these individuals so yeah like I was
like almost max-level people so just
love what my dude I can't love walk
anymore if they want me to do everything
perfect where I just die you know what I
found out in that game which is really
crazy
if your level isn't high enough right
and you try to go inside a dungeon they
say yo that like they tell you I saw a
little bit of an I stepped out of a give
you the like and I gave me tiger already
coming for you fraud Spencer it's
cancerous the game already started yeah
I hear you brother you can sit there in
the bushes with no game pass do here
chases 1495
I'm gonna take my 1495 it's the opening
game pass and get your dreams with that
yo man what's up brother is good uh no
yeah they welcome you to have King like
mentally you have to be on another
wavelength to say I'm gonna take $20 and
buy one game or I'm gonna take that same
$20 get change back and get 200 games I
don't know what wave the kid has spoken
and of course we had the Lord of the
cooperative experience and gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lore Cognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP now tell me which one a a but
what you need to hear so on basic stuff
men are must feel Baraka and phantom
dharak
on the switch men absolutely love it if
you love XCOM and you love espionage spy
stuff mixed together back in the day was
that my interpret is a by chirping oh
here we go
you inferring that my profile said I'm
on PC sir is that what's the bougie miss
with that sir I mean the other question
is how does the premium gamer not on PC
oh you've been oh yeah you know even
before me even though me you can play
these games on PC boy you know what
addict you won't and I'm not gonna live
because I have an alien to tell 88 inch
television upstairs and I'm really not
gonna sit here on the 40 inch monitor
that's not gonna happen that I'm sorry
I'm best with the boos I like to sit
back on the couch I like to say like
look at King over spend all that money
on a PC to do podcast like King was
saying yes I was trying out the new
Gameboy shouted a McCulloh Xbox Live and
Mike Ibarra man that thing's fantastic
they finally gave got an interface that
it's sleek I just love everything about
it the way you can customize even you
know good Forte they even got lfg built
in or for now in the joint I don't know
it is just so impressive
you got your resources in one corner you
know so I put a picture up we got all
these different options that you can
even listen Spotify integrate it on top
and for you control the dudes like me
who go to PC front you know you're not a
keyboard mouse do like everything works
with the controller like literally you
do not even have to touch the keyboard
mouse you just hit the Xbox Live button
like you want Xbox boom everything comes
up then you start moving around
configuring your Center fire fire fire
five that right there will get me to do
what at exam fraud no I'm waiting to get
his fraud alert cuz I know I'll be legit
when he did it I'm just gonna like a
little shelf on my head just put
and let it keep going all the other
entire podcast shout out shout out the
same Rob with his PC master-race
Rob from surgery up in everyone oh
that's myself monkey puzzles going on
y'all ready no Joseph
Elliott what's going on so yeah that's
pretty much it real quick I want to
bring some attention some here you hear
you talk before we get into the show and
uh yeah there's a lot of stuff going on
on the on the site right now just want
to bring it to everyone's attention
get that Lords a gaming dotnet when you
get a chance in a see this little
section right here check this out man we
got a shop right in is in the section
you hit that button
take your right to the shop and we got
them new flavors y'all we got the new
flavors right quick the Knights of the
realm is in the building
so make sure you count that support the
front in the back unison we got that
going on and then of course highly
requested we have the four horsemen the
gaming up in the spot
you don't saying all horsemen together
you know it's it again Lords gaming on
the back make sure you support and then
finally a little special commemorative
edition for all our peeps that went out
there to e3 the e3 2019 special edition
jump you know so again that is the back
of the shirt so y'all know off top still
got your on a little crest rocking and
rolling
so again if you get a chance I'll put
the links in the description we put all
that good stuff up
check out the iron law podcast shot we
got flavors you got that out a chance
sure King just some new flavors that
have been highly requested because I
know a lot of people wanted all the
Lords together so we got them all
together the horsemen and all that
citizen said I hope they make sure they
spell my name right he's shooting a shot
oh man shut up that's all I got or the
business front and we did with the Lord
our plane but I want to start with Lords
Forte and North slow-mo their video game
system history their journey its content
creators and of course what led them to
the scum cast and brat podcast so let's
start with more Forte from the very
beginning sir what some of the video
games you got what got you into gaming
oh man so I go back 27 tari 2600 man
that was my original I remember my mom's
put that I opened it up under the tree
lost my mind me and my little brother
used to go at that thing man and it was
it was glorious and then what really
really got me into gaming was Final
Fantasy 7 that was my first game that
officially told me that I was like okay
I don't like just playing sports games I
like playing other games too so I got it
to that game that was my very first one
it got me into going back to five and
six and I still think six is the best of
all of them up to this point do we agree
with that do you agree that I did hear
he's a Final Fantasy connoisseur the six
the greatest 60s addicts in the bush
then yes then six is the best the only
game I'm willing to to not even hit that
argument with innocence okay agree if
you split like I don't even think sevens
the best I think I really am true
besides eight I think six seven nine and
ten like they're around the same growl
just some are a little higher than
others yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
it's like six and seven on that broken
that broken uh elevator that just keeps
going up and down up and down
yeah seven seven was just more of a
mainstream thing for me six was like
that breathtaking experience and I was
like wow nice the main antagonist
exactly you know that isn't really all
there but he is everyone liked him for
his persona
well the main attacks were six is
literally crazy in the game he makes
people get down on the in the in the
desert you know he can walk over them
because you don't want to kiss shoes Sam
he or some official Bend any type of
time I like that there's a part in six
where he's just like why are we doing
this siege against this nation let's
just boys yeah he said three six and
tactics come in heaven fame jobs I think
that was my best one in the job like
three of them three or four first the
first time the jobs are implemented that
was in two or three shot at the semi
press guy he says seven popped up JRPG
cherries old ones they were seven is
overrated yeah I still think the spirit
grid was probably my favorite upgrade
path in any other final fantasies and
yeah that spirit great I love that
spirit cuz you can literally customize
every character to be what you wanted to
be in the very end game and if if you
wanted to if you wanted to take them
completely out of their element you
could so that was really refreshing
about that
so that was like probably my number five
game when it comes to like that top man
original man I went to the original
launch party for the original Xbox in
New York when they you know when they
were started in service everybody
yes how was this yo your father is you
probably saw us probably did man we was
all
younger girls running around being it's
at that point man I remember that I took
pictures and all types of stuff man it
was that was an amazing experience
halo of course is by far my favorite
game of all time that's the reason I
ended up there Microsoft through a Putin
my plan when they bought it and said hey
we taking this from PC my book went out
to Best Buy the day that halo got
announced on the Mac stage I went out
and bought any graphics car I went on
about a voodoo run then four decks for
that gang it was on you know it was on
the box he said this for Halo had the
halo ring would have sitting on the hall
I bought it man and next to God Oh III
Microsoft came Odyssey I was like well
yes no no so I had I had had to get the
duck is together and say hey you know
gotta gotta jump on his xbox thing and I
was already kind of used cuz they had a
partnership with Dreamcast recap systems
so I kind of knew where they were going
I played a heck of a lot of NBA Showtime
on that system did I was in my element
back when sports games is like a really
big thing to do oh yeah so I loved that
I loved it so much and then after that
man when I original xbox came out going
to other friend's house playing Halo or
having to go through the GameSpot
Network to actually link up with other
people
oh man it was it was an incredible thing
and then just the fact that I was taking
my xbox in a TV to someone else is how
just a beat down on him man shout out to
shout out to the number one magnet
system in the world no go ever behold I
know the two tested had you done brought
this telling the truth man beer all the
way across the map with Halloween oh
yeah that's like the best map
mr. ha yes that was like probably my
that was my favorite game but then
online here and I didn't expect online
to be as big as it was I was a day I
went to the mall bought Xbox Live in the
box with the headset yep so I joined the
community a day one make sure I get my
xbox live tag which is not a cool got a
day one so it was like bring your joy
like ice beam on to okay so the one I
have now is another one because
Microsoft used to have the putt they had
a policy before where you your gamertag
was tied to your credit card you
couldn't change it unless you like you
couldn't get it like recapture it unless
you do the credit card number that it
was under yep and Microsoft would not
allow even onto the email I had
information on the email and everything
that was under Microsoft would not
release that gamertag for me to get it
back so I had to literally go in and
make another version a nautical so I've
been on response like from the beginning
at this the nautical kind of have now
has been 16 years so I'm missing three
basically this crap out when we switched
over I didn't know that um the email
that I put in with my old game attack it
was melon Buster 1 and melon and say I
couldn't switch it over so all of my
game school all that stuff is just left
over the bushes made a man at the same
but I think that happened to everybody
that went that happened to unless you
was able to keep all you you kept the
same account and you knew the
information that's the only way it
didn't happen to you didn't I see what
happened to me was similar to King I
have my account under my my college
email and so then like one that wasn't
like graduated college
wow they just shut my email that
into it like you know it was like oh no
your your your username is tied to their
game attack aside to that my all right
well guess all those that game of school
points and all that stuff all that stuff
is gone I had to start all over
yeah I gotta give a fraud alert to
myself because all that crap I was
talking about PlayStation really was
like yeah you couldn't switch it joined
Microsoft already did me dirty before
Xbox people were prepared 20 15 years
ago for this yeah oh yeah so nautical
since the beginning man and then when X
my slide launch man I jumped the end was
playing a lot of basketball a lot of
football but man the first game Ghost
Recon the original because network that
was the game that told me I don't need
to play sports games no more right
nothing but shooters for the rest of my
freakin life glad you mentioned that
like yeah I was there I was on that game
man it was amazing how many players was
on one team at that time when I ate on
ate at that time right now did they have
like a versus the AI like it would be
like it was like like almost like a
terrorist hunt but like it was in the
open fear I just love that game yeah
once you're the first one that that one
was where you in order to get the
weapons to use online you had to go
through the single-player campaign to
unlock them you had to beat certain
missions to get all the weapons a man
man once I was probably the number two
clash out out to the infamous fan those
my peoples I still friends with them to
this day one of my blades one of my boys
sees he's a top streamer on on Twitch
he's doing this thing so shout-out to
that man but man those that right there
is what my competitive side of gaming
really came out just I read
tournaments or tink appeal it was a it
was a real amazing experience and then
it just transferred on and on with
destiny well not that she was more halo
just getting into gear as a war Gears of
War was that
- man and it was just it was just an
amazing ride just through that original
xbox and then Mass Effect - Oh bro
alright when I tell you something man I
might have to rethink I might have to
rethink my favorite halo halo is
probably my favorite game halo probably
two and three
Mass Effect is my favorite franchise
that I I was one of those people and a
lot of people are in the situation they
played the first one they kind of got
stuck when I'm planet or somewhere they
was like if you had to do like
especially if you're achieving hunting
my wife called me but especially if you
achieve my hunting you like looking at
she was like oh land on a planet that
has been unexplored yeah landed on this
planet and I couldn't get off the planet
Normandy so I was like you know what
screw this game in the bushes go back
and play some more halo halo it did let
me tell you Mass Effect 2 came out in
Como tropical you know my brother called
me was like bro did you play mad did you
check out Mass Effect 2 I said no one
yet first story he said play the first
mission that you'll be back here so I
win here and I was play the first
mission my scheppers floating into the
planet's atmosphere done can't play no
more this gotta go back to one gotta get
get my character I got my bro quick real
quick real quick
did you kill Ashley what did you kill
Rex we remember that situation yeah it
was well obviously
honestly I you do anything
Ashley did it for me I didn't we'll see
I didn't expect that I was like trying
to play both sides of the fence
it did all of a sudden Ashley was like
enough of this nonsense and blasted rec
center Oh
that's actually they had to get the heat
because I was keeping Rex wrestles my
dude that's well that well you gotta
remember that was the first I believe
that was the first one that actually
death that matter because because Ashley
and what's the name was uh what's the
guy's name can I think that came after
that when you had to make the decision
before that one but it was like Rex I
didn't expect the perma death thing I
knew it was in the game but I kind of
wasn't thinking about it at that point
it was she pulled the gun else I know
kind of renegade or Paragon rating you
could talk him down and I pretty much
was like yo look ray only the only
experience I've ever had with something
like that wasn't Oh dawn I remember the
the asian chick I was trying to keep her
alive and she was going off these little
oh this little that grind up stones and
stuff it was like a conveyor belt oh boy
yeah yeah and I was like okay I was like
alright alright and I remember I wasn't
paying attention I was do I think I was
on my phone and she tripped and grabbed
one of the minutes like press X so peace
rex y'all for all ya recipes rex man it
was it was not having a mini game going
towards the rest of it but man that was
an enjoyable experience I let the I
destroy the collectorship I refuse to
have it yeah I lost jack in the process
of it you know she yeah Jack I lost her
right then and there I was thinking
about going back and redoing the game
and it was like no I'm just gonna stick
with what I got Misha
yep yep the suicide mission and that was
an amazing thing and then mad people had
a problem with massive threat Metinvest
victories ending me personally yes it
could have been better right but I got
all the people that says yes it could be
better buzz damage control charlie
but see this a thing the ending could
have been better but the part that you
get to when you're going up to where
you're making a run up to the citadel on
the ground on earth you're going through
the buildings and you go to that earth
hug city before you gotta make the final
push to the mission you get a chance to
like talk to every last one of your
people all the people that you ever baby
he came in contact with that was part of
your squad you got a chance to like tell
them how they felt about you and
everything and they got to tell you that
was closure for me I was like I'm good
and when I to the very end I decided to
destroy and let me tell you whoever
thought of this was genius I walked over
to destroy I thought about it for a
second I pulled the trigger at the
reactor nothing happened I was like oh I
think you probably the first person in
history that's called Casey Hudson a
genius that was a jido it was G because
here are your three options even though
you had everyone's playthrough is
completely different literally every
single person who's played this entire
series playthrough was completely
different you got three ended okay no
listen bro I'm not popping a call we
gotta wrap this up right now you need to
quit so what I was saying period sir my
sphere is not yours and everybody knows
it is freaking universe at Boston gang
serious I walked up to the reaction
where we trade for I pulled the trigger
yes and when I pull the trigger nothing
happened oh nothing happened it made me
contemplate my decision right literally
caught my brother on the phone who
beated a week earlier bro nothing
happened what's that I do should I
really be doing it he's like that the
games so good you have to call your
brother to fight that was great
like should I do you know bro do what
you need to do I said oh I hung up the
phone from him and I sat there for a
second I pulled the trigger again
nothing happened I was going on and did
oh you and your brother in the bushes
found out then I found out when you go
destroy you have to shoot it three times
it makes you shoot it three times so
second time I shot it nothing happened
it made me literally think I put the
controller down and walked away from the
game for 30 minutes I feel like you're
doing like a journey like it was a
journey innocent journey in the shadow
realm for two years to you for making
sure that you wanted to get it done you
mean to tell me that you talked to your
brother and he didn't tell you you got a
press a thrill I did not tell me bro I
think this is a fraud alert the fraud
alert situation because after the first
time if it didn't go right some normal
dude it'll be like you know what that's
it maybe they might check again right my
controller didn't work and he did it
again and it didn't have any like you
know what bioriod friends the times at
which it was supposed to work the first
time but you know bro your decisions
matter in this game confirmed by the
ending no they don't
i sat for 30 minutes on it and I came
back in and I shot it it didn't win off
and I say oh okay
done so like I said Andy could have
shouted did you go what have I done not
India I was in my I was I was pretty
much a prisoner I was a prisoner of my
convictions at that point I had to just
live with it he dedicated an hour of his
life I figured
and it was indicated more time to
figuring out than Bioware dedicated to
making a mess so that was it for that
and then probably the fifth game any
order is in I contemplate every time you
guys talk about people's top fives and
stuff I always say I'm not gonna put
destiny my top five I can't put destiny
in my pocket
I know I keep selling myself I can't I
keep singing I can't because I have a
real love/hate relationship with that
game
I really hate I hated destiny one part
way through and I started loving it I'm
here destiny to was it's been pretty
good throughout the Hopi but destiny
what kind of burned me a couple of ways
because of the way they marketed the
game it Amy really not like it and shout
out to the Master Chief collection not
working day one because that game would
work day one I would never play that's
me that's me again then I was telling my
original Rea team when when Master Chief
collection comes out this games in the
[ __ ] bushes don't even expect me on
this game anymore I'm done with this
game it did I went over there and I was
watching loading screens and Master
Chief collection and Seagal player
wasn't working and I was like okay I'm
going I need I need my Bungie fix so I'm
going back to destiny destiny man is in
my top five mostly just because it's a
love-hate relationship but shout out to
them they're the way that they're doing
the game now I am more confident in the
future oh yeah going forwards I don't
think you think you had the rear sister
in a second oh so it's Lord slow-mo did
very very intense history I know a lot
of it but I want to see if that get any
more gem from you what was some of the
first video game systems you had what
got you to game her over like it's
really similar before today a little bit
so like I'm am 38 now and I I was five
when when I first like really got my
first experience with video game
I went over to my god brothers house to
do had had the Nintendo Entertainment
System yeah Mario Brothers yeah duck
hunt and I was just like my mind was
blown
I was just like what is this I gotta
have this I'm talking to my moms like
mom I don't want anything for Christmas
but this but this is right but you know
me being a kid me not knowing our
financial situation where I ended up
getting was an Atari 2600 in an open box
shout-out to L Shanna you go good
looking for the $2 super jet thank you
so much I'm glad that we can make that
day if you stay in a bag when she came
about was that I remember getting it
like so like she talked to my pops
my pops came through and he was supposed
she was supposed to wrap it up before I
saw it so he but he we were leaving
school he job stopped at my school and I
really remember this cuz I'm thinking
he's walking up with the NES and I'm
like yes yes and then I looked at I was
like it was at re 2600 were buncha games
though it had been out for a little
while
time out shout out to your pops for the
pimp decision because let me tell you
something you know what happened right
cuz this happen to my kids all the time
now I can go in and I could buy them new
stuff right oh I got a super deal from
the dude on the side that was that game
stop selling all his games and a system
that was just a little bit older than my
son didn't have yet so you got a pimp
decision then he gave this crap ton of
game and shout out to your pops he got
the side dealer gangster I feel so I
mean I eventually did get a get a NES
and I became a Nintendo fanatic for a
good long time like alright I wasn't
like in the console war in hating on
Sega
I wasn't L wasn't much of a Sega do you
like they were my best friends we get
all the second stuff I feel all them
Tendo stuff and so like whenever we
wanted to play you know one of the other
you know few boys house played play
that's a go you know coming hey come
over here be playback right your man had
the console go over your maker blue
check it out slow-mo do you remember
that culture like you played on the
basketball court are you playing on the
field and then slip out somebody be like
yo I got a say go I got a turbo graphic
so even like were I got this and it
wasn't that oh you got a Playstation let
me punch you in the mouth it was it was
only get to his house so we can just you
know swap swap and play and play my
friend down the street from me man he he
had like the original Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles love that game on NES no I
went down there and said bro here he
said what you got I said I got my
contract my life force I got my Mario
like oh my god I mean I met you right
all the mega mans he's like yeah which
one you won't in literally we would have
each other's games for like taking his
back yeah so let me speed this up a
little bit man I got to let's see I was
always on my Nintendo but then like when
I started getting to RPGs for real for
real it's like so I got Final Fantasy 4
which was Final Fantasy to here really
really enjoyed it but I was like it I
still wasn't really into it like that I
was still playing other games but then
when Final Fantasy 6 came out which was
our Final Fantasy 3 is when I was like
I'm hooked
yes the story is fired I you know kefka
was pissing me off or I was like man I
gotta finish this game so like I'm
playing this game I'm in high school at
this point loving this game and I'm
talking to this guy at my school he's
like yo Final Fantasy 3 isn't as good as
Chrono Trigger and I was like like what
do you smack right so but I'm I am they
play Chrono Trigger before so I'm like
well I I mean prove it to me so we
traded games
okay so we're anything what you hit him
with would put a Chrono Trigger what you
get
I sold on Final Fantasy 6 was better he
and believe me so we have to trade those
two games Wow
so I got Chrono Trigger and I was like
yo man you know that game good grief
like you changed everything
coach it was lit so first game ever
played to have multiple endings yep I
mean just like it was it was so amazing
and so the day so we say we would do a
two two weeks rate the day let me ask
you right before I will see him in class
was after my gym class and then gym
class I got the game in my locker some
dudes as though it is in the locker room
smoking weed yeah coach comes through
the locker room they threw their weed
into the first Locker they score and ran
out this is not this is no lie seriously
I'm outside for gym and their smoke just
coming out the locker room I'm like you
know the fire alarm oh God oh I'm
laughing like I'm laughing like my man
my locker bird all up come back in the
locker room it's my locker oh all my
stuff gone Crone sugar guy now bear my
yeah the school and the county was like
we're gonna reimburse you for everything
so your clothes everything your books
everything you had in there so I mean I
told him I had Chrono Trigger in there
yeah I mean I told him I had like more
games
how'd you get all that you'll be back
don't worry about is well said tell me
I'm lying
I wish she would have VCR tapes in there
because I was big with Nintendo until
they tried to pull a boss move and
stickers on look I still have n64 but
when Final Fantasy went over the Sony or
where I went over the zone now a bit
please me I'm uncool to Gaza and they
still had the best wrestling games THQ
yes held it down on the n64 and that's
pretty much primarily where I played
that and Smash Bros is what I played
with my friends but when I was like four
my own single player experiences Sony
was where was that Final Fantasy 7 that
trash Chrono Cross Chrono Trigger
wannabe game I played through that I
played through everything I had I man I
mean Metal Gear Solid oh all that great
stuff man so like I really got into that
but then when the Xbox came out man halo
Kane mmm look like when forte was
talking about how you have these big
land parties mm-hmm and then you get
halo and you get there like we'll get a
switch don't just be that workload you
get a net licks way to get that joy is
war tvvv everybody became network
engineers when that Jake everybody away
what you gotta do we gotta get this all
hook there you know just shine get you
your power your power
image me though love girls you don't
cause a fire now oh man I was the level
of word-of-mouth
when you found out that you can net link
your systems together because they
didn't really explain it to you know but
people found out they found out and the
condenser in the community did yo let me
tell you what you could do with halo
what you can link that up like that this
is what you need and when you
financially figure that because you know
I know Microsoft knew but there's like
financially can't with tell these dude
to do this
yeah like financially we can't be liable
for what's going to happen here when we
did this because you know on the weekend
Channel 5's that's our base that's our
foundation 16 dudes I cannot stress the
city and the reason why it's so amazing
to me to this day is because shout out
to my auntie for dealing with a house
full of 16 teenagers yeah playing oh me
the love I couldn't do it I couldn't my
kids would hate me cuz it's not gonna
happen the Queen mama Cognito
go down we linked those up and we played
and these experiences when you say it
I'm like here are doing the exact same
thing like when slo-moes talking I'm
like yo this is crazy you don't sin
shout the sin in it because it just
shows that I was a lot it was the same
mindset
well everyone did wherever wherever you
live that people were doing the same
thing it's crazy yeah you know you know
what I'm excuse me King I'll tell you
why she did it because a the same reason
why she did the same reason why my boys
mom did it while my parents was cool
with it they were happy to have 16 young
men young young black men yes in the
house and I'm not out in the streets
that was my argument slow cuz I told I
said you don't like when I'm outside you
don't like when we run in the streets I
said you know where I'm at we're just
here playing again and that's how
got that got it to finesse it and work
on you credit oh I remember I the only
time I ever recall this is me us like me
my and all my friends playing Halo all
night long and they realizing like man
the Sun just came I lost many
relationships would not believe that we
were playing games from 7 to 7 it was
like there's no way to cover the road to
in check but yep 7 to 7 they got to be
to work at 9:00 a.m.
slow tremendous history brother why are
we doing tough stuff I've got it alright
alright so honorable mention will be due
to that halo combat Evolved that's my
humble mention because just because the
all the time I put into it man it's
gotta be is that game that game was my
introduction it's the first-person
shooters and and the reason why I still
will always give a first-person shooter
a shot even to this day my number 5
number 5 is the Godfather of loser
shooters Oh Borderlands
all right he's gonna do Valera doing the
game that at this point right now still
has the best bill diversity of any Lula
shooter who has the most unique guns
I didn't blue the shooter and the only
Luther shooter that has a story that's
actually worth paying now you are you
see are you hearing these um these
expressions he's put it out other game
he's trying to dig he's trying to dig
miss something but he's trying to dig it
something but it doesn't hurt my
feelings because I agree with him
we gotta give that we gotta give that I
agree with you on that bro
there's always a foundation is always a
floor silligan a flooring so gays are a
lot closer to the floor before is fine
fancy six we talked about already but
yeah like that great story I love how I
remember playing the game and then
thinking how was at the end when you go
when you flew on on the city airship to
the the island in the sky you thinking
like I'm about to take this dude down
and that's a you know like it's a whole
nother half of the game and math has
changed and everything I got a refi my
squad again and get them all to govern
everyone has been through so many
different like in the time that you had
lost them they had gone through so many
different things all the characters were
so different and going through different
situations I'm like man this game is so
yeah that's that's my number four go
down number three Dragon Age Origins
Dragon Age origin then the laughs oh
you're the first person on aisle P to
ever mention and put any Delphi for
salute Khedive Dragon Age Origins oh
jaga these origins has an antagonist
where you defeat your antagonist to a
debate mm-hmm it's a debate among all
the Lords of an entire kingdom at the
end a game like this is completely
unique that's unique that's yeah it's
super unique
I loved how I could I get tackled each
area of the game in a different way well
I could choose to go after the elves and
get their alliance so I could choose to
go to the circle a major or I could go
after the doors but depending on which
one you you chose could really determine
like how difficult the game was gonna be
enough because I mean each area has its
own strengths and weaknesses and some of
those enemies were a lot harder to kill
than others the characters were awesome
and and I think probably one of the
better writers that bio it had daily
nadir
yeah it's higher lore for that story
David Gaider also wrote Baldur's Gate
a lot of other stuff that they did and
yeah just a shot to that game I love it
I play that game so many times or Lance
drags do we got we got rounded out
okay so we got Borderlands 2 final
fantasy 6 Dragon Age Origins number 2 2
is Mass Effect 2 that's 1 number 2 best
game of that series now for me
personally Dragon Age is my it I enjoyed
rightly Dragon Age series war the Mass
Effect but I have to recognize Mass
Effect is that trilogy is probably best
trilogy ever created in fact yeah is a
higher quality truly she packs a life
for today I didn't I didn't stop playing
Mass Effect when I played through one
and then I was like man you know what
let me play through it again as a
renegade just all renegade evil as
bastard at me yes I know what let me you
know let me go play through this again
as you know the old or Paragon every
time a massive that game came out I had
to do three playthroughs that make sure
I kept my game saves in but Mass Effect
2 that suicide mission oh good grief but
one of the best retention attention that
you had like you had to make the right
decision it wasn't it wasn't just say
you had to make the right decision with
the right member for the right job is
that you had to have their 100% complete
Lords yeah yeah and if you didn't have
that they would they would distrust you
in that situation and they could fail or
even in some situations if the person
fails someone else dies yes so and you
had to have your ship fully prepared
ship wasn't fully prepared you would
lose people just getting to the to game
oh that was great yeah all those guys
and so it's go to my number one my
number one is Chrono Trigger so that
that is my number one we talked about
early Kron sugar but like I said first
game I've ever played to have multiple
endings only game I can think of where
like no I think that was the first game
ever played that had multiple endings if
the first game ever played that had new
game+ yeah so I was able to go
ACK take all my characters and with
their levels and then you could actually
take on la voz and like the very
beginning of the game if you wanted to
if you have if your chrono was level 99
and you was just a G like that go ahead
and fight him it was like at the part
where the princess first goes into the
first portal and goes gets thrown back
into the Middle Ages you could choose to
go after her or there was another Porter
off to the corner if you take that
Porter off to the corner it will take
you directly to lava so you can you know
one-on-one with the dude I hope that's
405 later I like what I'm hearing from
y'all I got I got it I got it stay ready
this is some true game with top fives in
here man
Lord's impressed Mendes histories we got
a lot of show we got to move on we got a
lot of show to get into but um we gonna
hit these topics man and one I'm set
this off the first one off the back it's
actually a CD Projekt RED there's a lot
going on yeah you know there's a lot of
controversies in the street but I want
us before we get into the controversy
after I want to start off with the
positive first I just want to start off
with um just done as a developer like
where do we kind of see them at you know
where they are you're there your lohara
hierarchy so let's give it off set it
off with our Forte like just CD Projekt
we're winning he kind of ranked him as a
developer all day over ADT like where
you weigh that with them oh they far
from over 80 man it was them like when I
played the very first Witcher I knew it
was something special it was a little
broken and janky a lot of places but it
was a very enjoyable game the second one
when they came to Xbox I was I oh this
is this is way better this is a what a
better experience and then I play I also
played it on PC too so that was really
cool but witcher 3 man whoa Witcher 3
gave it set the bar so high for a game
of that magnitude the fact that this the
DLC is in some places are better yeah
the main story missions itself
sub
in truly breathtaking and then the fact
that they are all about just non DRM
they don't they don't lock their games
behind anything their games are just
available for anybody to play on pretty
much anywhere you want to when it comes
to my PC and I played pretty much all of
them there outside of the second Witcher
I think they are not overrated I'm once
I heard that they were beefing up their
team to make it a lot bigger because
they had a really ambitious thing they
wanted to do with 7.20 77 I was I was I
was like fine
most times will you hear people building
their teams to just like man how long is
this game gonna be good they announced
it in 2013 the first time I was like man
that's already been 78-66 years since
then but when they said it I was like no
I don't care I'll wait cuz I know it's
gonna be fantastic when it comes out and
yes they are they are literally towing a
line that they can literally knock it
out the park or they can let people
drastically down and that's the one
thing I like about them because they are
not afraid of the pressure they put on
themselves today they are the developer
that day they play throw everything to
the wall and say this is what we make
this is what we this is our vision they
don't compromise their vision for
anybody and that's what I enjoy the most
about their games and we'll get into
that even more that's a virtue side of
it but dude I love them they're probably
not my favorite developer but when it
comes to them being an independent
studio yeah they are by far one of the
best out there and I salute them for
everything they're doing it okay who
needs a marketing team when you got
fanboys like you oh my god aah
shout out to you man we give you rush
that if you want them to rush that game
out in and and cap it at the knees more
power to you I'll wait to I wait to 2022
for that game if they had to come out
that long mm-hmm no they lured slo-mo
where do you have CD Projekt RED right
I think they're definitely tough I've
but done that my best developer because
I think their actual combat in their
games has been lacking it's the second
time I heard they're not my best develop
was talking what was his best develop
that's not your best
god bless the best no I'm just like I I
do appreciate their uh their improvement
over the years lie you take the witcher
1 it's okay you know but which ii was
story-wise amazing but to me i couldn't
finish the game cuz the combat just mmm
and the combat was so to me broken and
convoluted i just couldn't finish it
over but i really enjoy all the details
in the story and usually really all the
different characters i was meeting up
until I finally quit it but I got rid of
it yeah but like for them to go from
there and to The Witcher 3 The Witcher 3
combat it's not amazing but it is better
than wish you to and so now that all
that said when I saw the gameplay last
year aside for cyberpunk 2077 I said yo
this is this is the game went from yeah
I'm gonna pick this up for sure for sure
to I gotta get this game right now so
now like yet they are developer they're
one of the few developers that everyone
gives them gives them time everyone says
you know what for this game I'll wait
for it I'll wait for it to cook you only
get that from Naughty Dog's and we're
heard anyone say I want a game to be
rushed out I've always hear people say
take your time you know we don't want
the game coming out broken but when it
comes to this he acted like this is the
only studio we say that to like we say
that's every development there's a
certain segment of people who always
saying I'm one of those to say I'm never
about rushing games if
if I'm the kind of person is gonna be
like you if I want you to rush the game
and I'm also gonna not gonna pull knack
of playing when the game is buggy and
broken should be good I guess that's
what happens I don't know I don't mind
you know the hype towards cyberpunk cuz
it looks more like my style but like
people gonna act like they got this
how'd they get this clot from one game
well which is considered a masterpiece
bug well it's your three like I have
never ever seen the amount of clout
they'll develop can get from one game we
don't get this kind of clock to rockstar
yo that's how revered which it is dummy
you see people's avatars we do with
Geralt and you know dire wolf running
around like people going oh some people
you know some people do belong and
straitjacket just means that you're
below final fantasy that's not yeah I
have no one no problem with The Witcher
I I actually try to play it a couple
times I couldn't I couldn't get that
that fighting side now I just couldn't
like it just seemed like kind of like
clunky at times like it what the the
atmosphere than the witcher's probably I
don't think there's a game that quite
captivates you more like The Witcher
mmm-hmm The Witcher 3 I don't know about
the other two guys but you know this
one's first-person and I tend to
gravitate towards more towards those but
they're they're probably the top five
studios I don't even really like the
games like that until cyberpunk comes
out and see that's why I am that's why
I'm like their games are okay
but I can recognize quality I can
recognize that a ton of people are
obsessed with the games they've come out
with and be like you know what alright
and the fact that they get that kind of
clout I can put them in the top up for
me personally it's just now this is
gonna be my jam all the time they might
be topped - whoa rapid a building was
going on I'm a head did the fraud alert
on you
you walk in the room you look I agree
with sig the combat the comments a
little shoddy it's not the strength of
the fighting mechanics the whole game no
some parts that work so well together
look let me tell you something that the
the the breeds of The Witcher 3 is that
even the side missions don't seem like
tedious side missions they make sense
you don't mean like if you play the
bloody baron the money what it's one
hell of a story but it is if you if
you've read the books - the fighting is
with his fighting style girls fighting
styles based on like books that the
fighting combat style is broken we don't
want to hire an actual person because I
don't think they actually had any woman
that was specialized in combat design
working for they've all really confirm
that did they finally win gasps no look
what they did with The Witcher 3 was to
me it's still gamers generation to
generation but the
because you can't just judge one part of
the game it's a leaf okay good
everything slow-mo the thing is though
it has not at least get everything
slow-mo here's the thing man are not
cancer because that's where it's it's
where the Lord's other things can make
up for the lack of no no nothing can
make up for the lack of it so the fact
is you like the crafting and it's okay
know the sport with a story telling the
world how immersive the world is and the
characters and how unique characters
sorry like if it's something small like
something nitpicky that you don't like
that's one thing but if it's the combat
the core of the game and that's not the
greatest it goes down a letter
automatically automatically you verrat
well it's that you continue on your
Frodo no look guys I mean look there's a
week the game yes I would say it's I
would agree with you it's it's the
combat but I think the rest of the game
for me at least like it wasn't it wasn't
a new experience was like I can't stand
the combat like yeah the combats wasn't
a strong part of the game but the rest
of the game the exploration of the
character development of the story the
just the the the way the game just kind
of sucked you into that world in it I
was able to overlook that one weakness I
mean it wasn't it wasn't game working
for me it's not game breaking I feel
like like CD Projekt RED got like these
concentration cares for coming back he
said Lord addict didn't finish though
you have no opinion in the brain
did you I didn't like the car finish the
game though it doesn't matter it does
matter it absolutely does measure do you
finish 80% of the games you talk [ __ ]
about I don't finish language as well no
how did you play massive you played the
massive a trilogy right I played the
first two I didn't play the third so you
played the first one in the first one
that comment was awful yes it's awful
still good game it was still a good game
when was Mass Effect made no matter no
seven what year was the witcher 3 made
as you completed the game and you and
you you play the second game you will
see that the combat system for the third
game for the second and third is so much
improved in their game because and the
second game had issues hitbox detection
was off and he was terrible I must say
this entry game into addicts defense if
something irritates you yeah in a game
and it's broken and this is the main
this is just the crux of the game is the
action fight an adventure game an RPG
slash RPG if that aspect of the game is
broken because it's broken I've died
plenty of times because of a stupid
fight mechanic the lock on the get lock
on um that made me just say I'm at the
bushes I mean this is the debate that
comes up sometimes with a red head right
a lot of people shout out the dizzy they
in a completely different section here
we go here's a $2.00 attic Snickers
okay let's take fallout 4 I don't like
that game I think fallout 4 has a lot of
flaws it's not a good Fallout game it's
a good first-person shooter game but at
the end of the day fallout 4 was
lackluster on a lot of features that's
been in fallout but guess what was good
at the end of the day the battle system
the mechanics of the game when it comes
to fighting people guess what it wasn't
good so what's your three fighting
system that's why I dropped one and play
the other listen there's enough for
everybody but we don't everyone okay but
uh Lloyd King I know you had a lot to
say
so all right the first of all they're
not the develop a degeneration
without computer
you're not gonna roll the hyperbole
erection now maybe they have some of the
most intriguing characters and I'm not
gonna lie I play 1 2 & 3 right I
finished one a finish - I didn't finish
3 the reason why I didn't finish 3 and
this is I'm a give them kudos for all
your um DLC Esprit I'm a given cool very
consumer friendly everything they do
with the HDR we're fixing the framerate
fixing the bugs
we're with we're sticking with you
through your purchase that's what you
want every developer to be right now
I gotta go with addict on this part if
your joint is based around fighting
combat and that's broken bro you are
broken that's not the main crux of the
game it's not it's not it's not you guys
are comparing it to like like
blood-borne I'm not comparing it to that
but what I'm comparing it to his games
of its ilk now you're gonna say in other
aspects it's stronger than games of its
ilk right yes when you talking about our
Beyonc
when you're talking about storytelling
out I'm talking about character
development when you're talking about
all those other things I hear what
you're saying that those other things
lift level a weak fighting system but
for somebody who's actually
out there fighting and if our role from
a wolf to in running to and another a
Valkyrie our war with those of those
armed Griffin Griffin roles in army I'm
so pissed off I checked my controller
controllers because you're whack
fighting system I'm not tight enough for
me I'm sorry
nervous for other people they may yell
up this game at a generation games in
category you have them where do you have
them people like using Metacritic or
when it's gonna be just like bringing up
numbers and system cells when you decide
to say oh because like true turbo
graphics sir nobody liked my turbo
graphics but me no more graphics right
but it was me and you and the bushes
together these weirdos is bugging that
Keith Courage's in the garbage mine
playing Bravo man and stuff like that
what it wants venture yeah I don't look
to somebody else to tell me what a good
game is that right so that that part
that what am i I'm explaining about this
developer they're nice and maybe this
game that's coming up the cyberpunk
coming up maybe this game is their
pinnacle my problem is this if this part
with this great game The Witcher the
fighter mechanic was broken if their gun
game ain't all point and I've been
hearing rumblings baby
a gun game ain't on point we're gonna
take this cyber pump and push I don't
care how good the ambience is the
character development is if you in a
first-person shooter and your gun game
eat legit you know bushes
fair enough that is where you are see
reacted like between all all this
character development all these
cutscenes and all this story development
they were like picking daisies or
something you're using the combat system
as he said which it three fire he said
this is why me but I also think there's
a difference between a shooters combat
system and a like melee version of a
comedy there's different ways you can
approach the combat in which it 300
crafting stuff like that you don't have
to use swords you could upgrade your
swords and stuff and then see you sorts
at all in this game I mean yeah you can
you can actually use like magic spells
and stuff you can beat the whole game
without using any swords you could beat
the whole game without swords you can if
you want to if you have the option to
yes either way
which is later we got a mover cuz it's a
big part of the second part which I'll
finish the first part look I see what
you guys you know obviously I'm kind of
I'm in the middle I'm kind of we're
attic and King are as far as the combat
drew me out a little bit but I do
recognize how important this but as far
as them as developer as an indie
developer truly remarkable what they've
done you know so far and that service
they got to GOG joint you know and how
they push him out there and you already
know how I feel about cyberpunk I think
he has to pretend you to be tremendous
so can't wait to see I think that's
gonna be more towards my likings my
feelings as far as the gameplay so we'll
see anybody that could do any better
do which III on the switch is already
clearly angry sure you can 64 that level
of wizardry is clearly which it three
with all the DLCs let me tell you what
the can I do something to make the
fighting better hey maybe I'll switch
you maybe wizardry the wizardry came in
when they made it for 60 bucks and they
got people just gonna go out and buy it
that's the wizardry we all here baby
so let's move on to the most important
part and obviously this is controversial
topic in reference to long - segment
sitting game
you know man if anyone has been under a
rock there's been a lot of uproar a lot
of people feel you know that there's
some content in the game that is
offensive you know one in particular is
a Haitian group in the game called the
Voodoo boys you know and um you know the
interaction with V who is the main
protagonist and them has raised some
eyebrows for certain people and then the
second thing is obviously in reference
to transgender imagery and there was an
image up there you know about game : i
believe that acts like mix it up and
some people felt no offense to it as far
as you know some game journalist as well
so i want to bring this to you guys
lures a start with um there's no a
breath because I know me and Bradley DMS
and you know he's on one side I'm on
other side no no I don't think we're on
different sides of it kind of like I
don't know like in the middle somewhere
in the middle and I love having rap on
because one thing I like about rap is
that even though we disagree we can
always have intelligent discussion yeah
let's talk about it bro like where are
you at with this the whole controversy
needs two dicks alright so with the
transphobia stuff I know that a lot of
stems from a meme that the CD Projekt
RED had tweet
last 2018 I don't I don't have the
Lincoln I think I may have shared that
link with you kognito so out if you have
a chance to look at it hmm
um so that's kind of where this this the
trans the idea of transphobia started
but at the same time if you know and
this is kind of where I was you know we
were chatting about Cindy and this is
kind of where I'm trying in the middle
and I still don't know how to really
feel about this which is Mersey like
when I first saw the tweet I was kind of
like yeah it's probably not good and
then they apologized and then there's
that imagery you know in cyberpunk 2077
that we that that's been going around
and I'm like you know given their
history is this a good look you know how
do I feel about this but then you know
knowing the background of the game that
it's a tabletop game that's instead of
dystopian of our world and you know you
could pretty much the idea of the world
is pretty much you could be whoever you
want to be right even change body parts
and yeah you can interchange body parts
and the developers allowing you to
create your character how you see fit to
you you're giving that that freedom that
option and then you know you know I've
seen some people the obesity community
kind of voice their displeasure with you
know with tweet last year 2018 and then
write this image but then I've also seen
the mother people say oh it's not really
that big of a deal so hmm you know I get
context is important here like it is the
is the imagery that we're seeing the
game is it there for shock value or is
it there because it does something to
drive the narrative or hmm add to the
you know to the atmosphere to the game
and then if you know the background of
the game you could probably say yeah you
know what
this is dystopian environment you could
be anything you want to be and maybe
this is just an extension of that idea
and that's with that you know that
imagery reflects in the game and so if
that's the case then maybe it isn't
necessarily as offensive as people might
think but you know I think it's just one
of the things master on offense man III
cuz I look here to think like III do
want to buy the game you know because
I'm interested in the world and like I
said they're probably the top two
developers and imagine if this game this
game is gonna drop in what 2020 yes and
if this game is as good as a lot of
people are saying who have seen it
behind doors mmm
I mean you're looking at maybe yeah hair
[ __ ] wait yeah you looking at
I mean let's say this guy just said you
know which of three got 92 Metacritic
what this game gets like a 92 medic
rated 93 then I mean they've dropped to
game of the generation in one generation
that's great
you know what you can get out there get
out the blue light right now King accent
were in the game drop King and he gets
93 Metacritic I'm gonna have you on Brad
I'll bring out the blue license I want
you to call me on Brad but don't talk
about that committed critic crap oh but
what I would say is if that game tickles
your fancy letter tickly that's it if
these games
if Witcher 3 and I don't care what
anybody says about anything when you
Punk your money down nobody around you
chipped in
alright so not a soul around you is in
there cheering you on as no foundation
is Brad in the store purchase on Brad
so whatever you buy love it enjoy it to
help with what anybody says I don't care
if the combat is broken for me it works
for you so yeah I feel you 100% it might
be the game of the generation for you
yeah Brad my wit I didn't get a chance
to speak doing it in DM in reference to
the the voodoo boys which is the Haitian
oh I wanted to ask you you know how you
felt about what you read in that context
is you know did you feel a way about
that and you feel that offensive things
there um again I didn't find it
personally offensive mm-hmm but I could
see how some people money okay you know
I think I you know I just think it goes
down to what I think it just comes down
to one of those things of individual
like you know like oh I see it's like I
have a hard time with this stuff is like
something there's some things I
definitely do find offensive mm-hmm but
I think as humans if it's if we're not
part of that group sometimes I think
it's like it's hard for us to kind of
feel that and we need the right word you
know if it's not directly yeah I'm a
Latino right right so you know I mean
when I see the kids you know on the
border you stripped away from the kid
you know that's all but wait a minute no
but you know but if you're not in the
group I think it's hard for sometimes
for us to relate to that
and then you know it's it's again if
you'd ask me personally no I wasn't
necessarily offended by that
okay um there was that interesting the
video clip that you sent me where it was
a YouTube clip I think right they're
trying he's going yeah yeah where the
money's going and you know is it if I'm
trying to draw a fake outrage to drive
money to to get hit so the song I don't
know about all that man that sounds like
a lot of tinfoil conspiracy
you know I don't get down with that but
I know I feel but the media big shout to
solve any chat at the doctor's office
cursing because it is strawberry of a
snowman you talking about oh I see you
at the doctor getting Nunis cyberpunk
knees you can run faster from the knee
chopping great timing a Larry let's gift
would say it and slow it so fort a man
just about the controversies from what
you've seen how you taking all the stuff
in offensive where you have alright so
it's like a broken record back and I
agree with brat 100% it's like if you're
not a part of something you're not a
part of that actual group you it's kind
of hides hard to identify I mean be an
african-american we all know how we feel
about certain things and other people
kind of don't feel the same way that's
because they don't live in our shoes
they've been through the things we've
been through so so ultimately this
doesn't offend me but I can see why I
could offend some other people but I'm
all about when the developer makes a
decision in a game I want the decision
to be what they wanted to be and not try
to be forced like have a narrative
forced on them they can't have what they
want that's the one like we get the
games that we get nowadays you know
controversy or not sometimes the reason
they're as good as they are is because
the developer
we're gonna do this in our game and this
is the this is the this is what we want
our game to portray and it's our game to
see you know we talked about this on
breath the other day we talked about it
we call a duty and there you know with
the whole controversy around that game
with kids and stuff and families and
everything and I felt the same way about
that you know ultimately somebody put
the story together and said this is a
story I want to tell mm-hmm and be it or
not there's a story I want to sell yeah
okay fine you can say that too because
guess what you your job as a writer is
to sell your story that is your that is
the job the story is what makes the game
think about it the reason we all went
out and bought the reason we all got
tricked it's a destiny the first time I
rise because we thought it was a story
today so we all know that stories the
reason they do this so anybody that says
that you know some of this stuff is it
for shock value I think 90% of it is for
shock value but that doesn't change the
fact that I think that it's a message
behind it and if it hasn't been movies
that's come out like ready player one
and stuff that's shown that you can be
whatever you want to be in a movie and
now we're starting to see that type of
stuff more and more in gangs yeah I can
see it's starting to it's like we're
blurring that line on so many different
media points I'm starting to think that
people are starting to think like well
movies is okay games are because we
still consider games to be a childish
media where it's bigger than movies at
this point in some ways so that's what
people need to start really thinking
about like this is a billion dollar
industry and yes we do have 15 like six
seven all the way at the 15 year-olds
playing on the system but guess what the
people the people that push this this
narrative forward when it comes to
buying this stuff is us then 25 to 40
year old guys they've been playing games
ever since 1986 and stuff like that so
this is the stuff that we want Nintendo
is starting to get it that's why they're
starting to show a lot more games of
amateur raid nature on their stage I saw
more mature rated games on Nintendo
stage that's
Microsoft's honestly so we're gonna cut
the bondo - I was offended by the
hilarity
I'm not saying that they won e3 that
they showed us a little bit more of what
most people weren't and maybe there's a
little blind because they never really
show it before so it seems like it's a
lot more than normal because it is no I
want to frame rate and graphic sir I
didn't see that okay well yeah you
didn't see that but you see but there
was still way more than you used to see
in think I have no problem with it I
mean I understand why people do yeah if
you do just remember the developers made
this choice for them and for the people
that want to play the game and know why
kid just don't buy it again it kind of
can I just interject one quick because
I'm gonna bring this one point I can
also understand like why a may like you
brought the Voodoo boys well I that may
not personally impact me I mean I see a
problem I can also see why people are
bringing up issues with it because
they're concerned about the portrayal of
minorities in this game and that's
probably no but I could see that I can
understand why people would feel that
way you know began and I'm not gonna you
know I'm not gonna say that you're wrong
for feeling that way but I could see
that I could see there's you can be
empathetic towards yes exactly
I get it I get shot the big cloud game
with all my brother the professional $2
super chat was good lord keep up the
good work and it she taught me in these
shootings but we're gonna let on home
slow get in cuz I see slows chomping at
the bit
no I uh oh we brought the guess we need
that one let's talk about some truth
here the truth is is that this whole
story was created by a black man an
african-american man so when people try
to say things like oh the voodoo boys is
racist
a black man created the Buddha boys what
are you talking about how is he being
racist against himself it's a whole this
whole mentality in gaming media now
where people don't have any information
on the entire topic and the Nation about
their Oracles talking about oh this is
racist and that is racism I don't know
if there's actually a YouTube video of
Haitians after they saw the of the
actual reveal yep and they said that
they got me in it it's exactly how it is
a representation like so how is someone
else that is a group going to say it's
racist but the people that they are in
that Margaery back not like that you're
free to wish for nothing that's what to
generate views and to generate traffic
they have no intentions on there they're
not upset they just want that money yeah
yeah Eleni no euro you need to have
about to shoot the guy the guy was a gun
shot gun whatever that gaming that game
you got two white males who I mean if
they want to be allies to to you know
people of color then cool but you need
to know your role when you know Wes I
know your role I'm not trying to be the
trouble I'm to say hey look when we need
your help
didn't help don't jump out there without
knowing anything about how black people
feel about this game but he made the
article white - yes and they try to tell
oh that's racist
I laugh so hard because you know stop I
say well ma Boulet hey I know exactly
all of that stuff so I've seen and I'm
like yo yo they got the culture down
package it but then the transphobia
thing we're at a point right now where
you know um and in the hypersensitivity
in where people are in this in this
generation the hypersensitivity with
these individuals
listen you want your games to allow you
to be and do whoever whatever you want
to do right so you're talking about in a
future right we're at we're at the point
right now where those lines are being
blurred in reality facts so you're
talking about in a future that is so far
ahead you really think that stuff really
matters so I want to be able to make
whatever character I want to make I want
to be able to do and cross do whatever I
want to do you know that's what the
future is looking for that's what
they're talking about right now yeah
okay you know what's funny
the same people that are complaining
about the same people it's like give the
developers freedom you know I could
serve again I could certainly empathize
with their point of view I think because
of people way way way wait III think
that I understand that too simple but I
think this is I think some of this is
stems from any historical perception of
how minorities have been portrayed in
media right and the betrayal of of
minorities in media and film and
television exactly hasn't been exactly
positive in this case
and so it's like with every when a you
know with Jadakiss had said you know why
did uh what did why the dunzo have to be
crooked before he took it I mean there's
message behind that I mean see denzel's
best world wasn't training there's other
you know and so it's he's saying why
why is it that we have betrayed me I
guess but I want to ask you this
Baptists know most about the bone in the
building Chris Tucker with trans and
Fifth Element
yes cyberpunk is fire I don't think he
was do that's the perception it was it's
not it wasn't a concrete fat it was just
how it was played out you know it wasn't
anything that we really thought about
why are we so hypersensitive and this
point in time with I think something has
to do with current POTUS to get into the
political part of it yeah what if what I
must say is this right just I just want
to elevate that point that bone said it
wasn't we didn't care we was laughing at
Chris Tucker playing a character that
was in a movie right and nobody sat down
was raising pitchforks and yelling that
this is happening or whatever right in
this game which is like I said it's the
fall future mm-hmm whatever happens or
whatever is written into this game is
not meant to be taken literally right
now right good point though he said
context is everything but what have we
come to when we can't even explore
controversial subjects in fiction thank
you we gotta let slow finished over yeah
I was gonna say certain people just have
voices now and they always had a voice
those people always been there wasn't
loud it just wasn't loud enough now what
the with social media being the way it
is now everybody has a voice and you
just hear and we always say people hear
the loudest of the loudest the most and
that I've always is I've always said
that when it comes to subjects like this
you have catalysts on the internet that
just revolt that whole subject like you
know the whole thing with Intimus with
neediness accuse you when she got behind
that she got a following then you know
she she was where I'm looking for she
unified people that had that same
mindset now there's an entire army on
the internet with you made a tweet
saying that they need to be looked at
about CD Projekt I need to be looked at
for these things I'm saying because I
feel advice yeah she did say that I did
yeah you guys need chasing a chick less
little finish guys look so look this is
what I'm saying is that when when you
are not of the community and you're
claiming that something is racist
something is offensive to people that
you I'm sorry you you're never going to
understand what it's like to be a black
male and in they have that tension that
feeling when you get pulled over yep
you're never going to understand what
it's like when you go into a store and
one of the employees of the store keeps
following you around asking you multiple
times if you need anything you need me
think you question like you please leave
like right you don't unlike people of
privilege don't know what that's not
like so they should wait into people of
color
actually have a problem with something
then step out there then use your
platform to speak out about it yeah no
one is doing that when no but when we do
get people talk about they nailed us
perfectly no one say anything last year
when it was just hordes of white males
getting slaughtered in the 45 minutes I
burp on James Lakes no one said a word I
was offended slow-mo you you read it
once again you speaking from I do not
appreciate
0:03 thousand with the final future the
outrage a genuine fam they don't care
about us black people or trans people
[ __ ] generate clicks gotta stay
relevant shaking my head you're so big
let's so we look like you can ask
kognito I've done it a few times on on a
planet Xbox I don't even speak on
anything racist anything like that
literally they'd been so many topics on
Planet X Box I like look I'm not even
talking I'll just wait for the next
subject because I that's just a
sensitive thing like they knew when they
made that article that it was going to
generate cliques and it did so no I feel
that let me jump in y'all killing it man
this is I'm gonna be real King like I
ain't really wanna do these traffic
efforts I know you know you know we try
to stay the laws always try to stay away
from you know but at the end of the day
it did bother me you know I'm saying and
I gotta keep it real like I'm very about
inclusion in gaming like that is super
important to me so someone points out
certain to me is offensive I gotta hear
him out just to see what he coming from
so in reference to the fool boy thing
like be in there you know I'm saying and
like for me I could speak to that part
like as a man of color like I appreciate
when you watch a movie you watch a film
we play a game
and there's that authenticity with the
dialect and the reason I love that I'm
like yo that's hard um when I do that
accent way too well but like I get
excited when groups that are generally
not represented a lot in video games get
a chance to shine and it's done with
authenticity right and me hearing so
when I heard when I'm watching a demo
behind a closed door demo 83 and they
got this character plac'd and the entire
that Pacifica City is all it's like as
Haitians right so I'm like yo got King
I'm
sitting on my yard as Little Haiti right
right there's a lot of people that be
playing this game didn't even didn't
even know that individual that they
existed well you just lived it Liggins
my next point which is I immediately
felt proud of doing what my gut feel I
mean II felt proud cuz prior to that
demo
the only person of color I saw was to do
with the dreads and I was cool with him
right the buddy I was cool with them and
shad I wanna shout out Megatron cuz um
this is before my appointment he was
coming out of his the point my believe
and PlayStation brought l-boogie they
had an appointment with them before so I
said vaguely like what everybody look
like is you sold all right he's like bro
he's like he smiled he was just like I
didn't think they would represent us he
said I don't want to spoil it
I didn't think we would have this much
representation you know I'm saying and
after Washington I felt the same way so
I'm not afraid about that I'm not
offended by the voodoo boys I'm not
offended by the animals thing because at
the end of the day the animals group was
not all black the leader of the animals
group would you fight was a sub boss she
was a woman you know I'm saying their
whole thing is strengthen genetic
enhancements and getting a juicing on
and all that other stuff and then the
reason I called the animals they find
like like slow Mike Smith is black like
that that broom like I was like okay we
really understand what's going on here
so it's like you know it's a dystopian
future you know everybody separated in
groups no one trust each other and I
just struggle like Joe said what another
group who's not black to be and should
be offended now the second part is
sensitive because I want to talk about
that and it's this one hit home for a
couple of people that I know you don't
say that I'm friends with so I was you
know obviously the trans imagery we sort
of Cola add you know I look very closely
at the genitalia what y'all saw so
basically as a cola ad it says mix it up
Cola and yes you look closely at you
know female face but when you look
closely it looks like a penis okay
people were saying yo this is offensive
to the to the trans community so I wanna
I want to shout out to people and I'm
saying that I actually did some research
prior and they're friends of a friend
and I had to ask them you know I'm
saying because shots my friend Ryan
and other person I'm not gonna get into
you know for the context but on
basically their of the trans community
so I said is the imagery I sent to pick
I'm like this is from a video game I
didn't try to bias it with my feelings I
just honestly like yo what do you feel
about it said oh that laughs aloud so I
say yo do you find it offensive to trans
peas he said he said now I know that
cyberpunk 2077 I'm not mad at you said
actually that's my cosplay for next year
that's interesting my said he said plus
I haven't seen or heard a single trans
person worked up about this so then he
says people are mad at a fictional
future when they should be upset about a
factual present he says I won this game
so then I said what about the whole
aspect you know they you know you can
create a character you can change the
voices you can change all that stuff and
he said look at the end of the day I'm
super excited for this as far as trans
being far as the character created the
inclusion and it's it people are gonna
be mad no matter what to be honest I
don't have that time for that start that
type of energy and he said I don't like
people getting mad on behalf of my group
we have our own voice and Mary that's
what he said and then I showed him the
tweets about the dude you asuka's member
the other part of it was well CD Projekt
RED they got this history you know I'm
saying I'm saying you know stuff and
there was a comment somebody put in it
was like I want more guys and then CD
Projekt RED the twitter account said do
you J did you just assume their gender
he said no I love it he said it's
satirical he said to throw in the face
the people who are upset over a graphic
so to him non-issue I spoke to one other
person who is also part of the trans
community and they pretty much said let
know like flat-out there's no offense I
don't take anything from it I don't get
negative it and actually and that person
was not even into video games so I
actually respected that person you know
so you know in conclusion with this
whole thing you know mmm you know my
whole thing is look but video games is
my personal escape well I shut off the
world I get to gross myself and my
fictional character solo of my friends
but I gotta be real like I'm kind of I'm
getting lost like
concerned that we may be going down like
a censorship pass I mean like that's
just mean I'm just concerned where video
games going with this already because
like look we survived member hot coffee
from Grant you know what listen listen
you go for as far as the censorship goes
on what they gonna do is put a rating on
a box alright and that's all they can do
right now because they can't stop the
juggernut the juggernaut which is once
once they try to censor Mortal Kombat
remember to remember that right we live
through the Mortal Kombat outrage did
you know they're doing this and then
also don't forget that children are
killing people because they're playing a
beautiful games that's what I'm saying
right listen they put an M rating on the
box they're gonna put some on the box
and they're gonna put something on these
boxes and you just say sensitive
whatever I don't care what you put on
the box right the game is still gonna
sell put your little censorship thing to
make you feel comfortable within your
skin and allow us to continue to do
exactly what we've been doing that's
gaming facts with GTA as well remember
what we had that we survived hot coffee
we saw certain things and aspects that
you can do in that car in night time
when you are able to man I listen to me
when I tell you that that I think that's
what made Grand Theft Auto Grand Theft
Auto because everybody has these little
whatever's and when you able to outta
two in a game when you're able to do in
a game what you would like to do in life
it makes the game that much better and
when they saw how many people ran out to
find out about how to the gaming forums
you were like eh yeah check out hot
coffee before they pass it
yeah I guess I'm just I'm concerned I
just I just want to make sure because of
all those mothers advanced and their
member we eat the ESRB was with birth
out of this stuff you know understands
so I just want to make sure that I said
their visions are able to get out and if
that group that it's almost part of that
goo guy's defendant yes I respect that
but who struggle with people not in the
group you know I'm saying saying that
the leader of the black Appropriations
did white at least at least to make it
look good and have the guy that's
offended be Haitian I'm just saying
we're network but it's not working and
listen I wanted to ask you this to hell
with all that's yeah yeah right can you
talk about what did you play the game
and off I got watched every day and
David describing seems to me because I
wanted to get into the gunplay and
actually that was my only nitpick I just
felt the guns needed to feel more
visceral and I'm saying that was my only
nitpick but again bush I didn't know is
now when when the demo ends they all
hand out pamphlets and say hey give us
you know your cat rege one of the
shrimps and now as I said everything out
the game was fantastic this is this is
the next level this is like matrix play
run a deus ex Detroit became human which
all-in-one with the Mass Effect choices
I said the only thing y'all gotta put
he's just put a little bit more pop on
the sounds of the guns and I just want
more reactions when the enemies get
telling Nicole Bungie relaxed yeah if
they had one it's the perfect game they
got a ball where exactly you know I'm
saying that's no way from borrower
they're just joking I do have a quick
question I just want a run by Barone
real quick don't take a whole lot of
time on this but I didn't know that
there's a giant debate going on right
now about tifa's bra size oh yeah like I
heard about it at e3 but I didn't know
how bad it was
you guys know I don't criticize I will
say this sometimes I do think and I and
I and I came about this opinion not from
anything gaming related but I was
watching a movie about if you guys you
guys may remember Gary Hart who was the
Democratic frontrunner nominee for
president in 1987 for community eighth
nomination and you know he basically you
know he he left the he dropped out of
running because the you know basically
the Miami Herald had followed him and
found out he was having affairs with
every blah blah blah and they made a big
deal out of it and was front-page news
but and it made me think that sometimes
I think the media and I remember the
dialogue that the two journalists were
having that all you know we the people
deserve to know this and the people got
to do this and that I'm like it's
something I feel like journalists like
you know maybe you guys don't
necessarily know what the people really
want to give you exactly what they know
what they see up to the individuals to
interpret that you know it as they
choose now when a journalist takes his
own opinion and interjects it into the
the narrative of the story that's why I
have a problem with but as far as
journalists reporting on what's going on
if you're too sloppy in your business
stop doing your business I mean I think
for me it just it in the whole thing
with cyber paquimé if you think that you
know like I think sometimes not
everything needs to be an issue you know
or
screen is an issue and I'm starting to
see that now and I also think of fortune
it's a byproduct of that 24/7 and you
cycle yes like that it's just oh we got
to make stories like the whole thing
with the bra size thing that's a thing
right now no it's a problem virtual chad
has got leaves I've let him set off this
one which is rest in peace to the
Lockhart man reports are coming out
shout out to Jeff Gordon share the bread
Sam's that uh may be axed in the in the
Microsoft plan book man to play but
looks like they might be going with the
one skew effect and we have multiple
reports of Locke how rock are actually
no longer business so Lord addicts
asunder you gotta go to work soon let
you set this off man what do you think
you think this is the right thing for
them to go with a single console
approach which Scarlett and he's in the
plush's muting my mic cuz there's some
noise in there unmute are forgetting
nine unit okay
I I think it needs to go this way to be
honest with you I've always been I've
always said I'm not with that you know
across generation stuff because at the
end of the day you always have to build
for the smallest denominator so like you
can't really take advantage of the X at
this point because you have to consider
the S so it can't maybe go to like a
middle ground you know if you know ps4
if you know Sony's gonna go in for five
which is it's not been confirmed but you
know a lot of people think that for just
the specs that's in the console then you
know go for five two and have a middle
ground where you don't have to refresh
your consoles in four years okay so
that's way you ask so you're okay with
the single cause if we do it this way
we're probably going to get scarlet
exclusives mmm but if we don't do it
this way we're not gonna get Scarlet
Witch it's funny you said because what
was hinted shot the brass Samms was that
devs were telling Microsoft in reference
to both
excuse that okay if you guys have a la
carte we're going we're gonna work with
the Lockhart on the base level and then
scale up and that's not what Microsoft
wanted to hear apparently you can't
expect them to do extra work like that
especially then coming off you know the
Elvis gin like yeah so you know they
could do a lot better next generation
but at the end of the day we don't know
that dad's don't know putting that kind
of money behind a second SKUs gonna pay
off in the end because they might sell
worse next year because of this Jim yeah
it's a resource thing as well right so
he's again the vibe has been they were
starting with the lowest common
denominator and Marcus um apparently
thought about that I was like okay we
don't necessarily want to go that route
but I want to get for a table also in
our slow mo so fort say what you think
about man rest in peace Lockhart out the
liquor man what's going on man well I
think it's officially done for it I just
think overall Microsoft the message and
completely changed around that last year
they said a family they talked about
basically two things and this year not
even a peep of it Phil Spencer he came
out and said that he people are picking
his words I just think that at this
point unless they're trying to say they
want to bring something out later on
down the line like a year later that's
gonna be underneath skew I just don't
know why they don't make the ex that
entry skew gonna be a big thing I mean
what I mean for what I know the ex has a
lot of headroom left in it that people
are taking advantage of why can't that
just be the dream then why can't that be
the new Lockhart why can that be the 350
to 400 or $300 bucks going forward you
know so I think I think it's the
industry the industry's lashing back and
they they don't want all that extra work
like imagine that extra work that does
had to do this Jim okay the extra work
Jen's had to do this year but guess what
those devs so how many games on the Xbox
platform are they willing to just turn
that when you're putting double the
extra way way more on the place they
should platform what are you really
doing and I agree we're at it is that
what you're really doing is you're
driving them towards Sony with all these
additional excuse hey put your game on
our platform yeah
may sell more more copies but then
you're also putting in all this better
work but are we working on x86 still and
don't we all don't most of these
developers code for PC regardless don't
they code down anyway so hearing them
say that well we don't want we want to
code to the lowest denominator
denominator but then you code for PC and
PC is the highest so you could just down
scale from neck while that's why a lot
of PC ports come out after the console
yeah or don't come at all
honey you're talking about will see your
talk about the most ambitious ones like
red dead and but stuff like that but my
point is is the fit was that simple it
would always come out at the same time
you will almost every game would
probably a performance when Oded wants
their game to come out and not have at
the top of the lies thought they can do
but yet they're putting games on a
switch which they are literally putting
walls so you don't have to render
backgrounds to put it on the switch okay
but there that means they're going in
and they're redoing again all developers
are putting their game on the switch
they're outsourcing that to other
developers because if you have them
anyway what's your three that looks like
a ps2 game then you come back at me let
me ask you something
so Witcher on a switch are we gonna look
at blue pointer whoever is making a
switch version of that game or we go
look at CD Projekt RED about that game
no you go look at CD Projekt RED because
to get that slow are you talking about
the game oh yeah obviously so switch
when people play that game on the swish
and if it is a terrible experience it's
not gonna be like man that that
developer they had made did not have the
bandwidth
have the people to go put that game on
the switch with everything they're doing
right now but having more platforms or
more SKUs that you're gonna put your
game on then you don't have to look at
the facts out so have these development
teams just don't I have to do that right
now if they don't have the people to do
it then they're gonna go with the
platform which is the easiest to code
for to keep the easiest to put that
stuff on and going into next Jim we're
backwards compatibility likely is going
to have more people initially already
jumping in and that's the police-station
play Willie wants to be on a level
playing field with Playstation make it
easier for devs you not give them more
work to do I have a friend right now
it's just a little indie game - it's not
a lot and he told me that making a port
for another system isn't like making the
game again but it takes time mmm and
that's a that's a little indie game put
something on the size of of The Witcher
the size of cyberpunk they dedicate
entire teams to doing this okay so we're
talking about the lowest denominator and
let me ask you this do we really believe
Microsoft when they say they're gonna
support every Xbox
I don't equal word I believe there's
going to be a cut-off at some point just
like iPhones right is like I thought our
fault right Microsoft is bad at
communication that's different though
you don't think developers already know
that there's good Omega they know that
but we don't know that information it's
not speculation it's just a simple form
when they say no no card so no accessory
left behind what are we supposed to we
can't we can't sit here and say one boy
you can't say because there's no
information either I can't say one bad
thing we can't say it one breath that
they cold for the lowest but then on the
other end when games come out on PC they
code for the highest we can't live in
both worlds we can't do it is it's
important do you understand that when
developers put their games on PC and put
their games on consoles they have
two different teams within that
developer that are doing those games
I agree destiny was this okay so when
you say you can't say they're coding for
the lowest and then they'll see the code
for the highs these two different teams
come out for pc and and counsel at the
same time two different team one team is
doing pc and also they would think
there's so many times where games are
all organs like it's mid timeline the
develop pipeline you saying they don't
have time they have enough time to build
they have enough time to go out and pay
somebody else to make their game on a
different planet they keep the same
effort into a platform to the ground
like they literally outsource because
they don't have the resources and time
to do it themselves I know you gotta go
I have to let attic finish after that
slope you were your whole thing about
yeah yeah recipes Lockhart and I and I'm
glad I'm glad for us and then piece of
all the bad idea in the first place
I'm was wondering like especially when
they came out when Club Rio came out
with his little documenting and I'm
looking at the specs of it I'm like
that's barely more powerful than the 1x
what's the point of this what is the
point of this when you already have a
one execute just came out with two years
ago that is still a viable platform
right now I'm like this is the making
that water is just weird to me
so yeah whatever you can do to make sure
developers are happy with your platform
they want
put their games on your platform even
now even now right and we all seen this
it happens every gym last gym it was the
360 this will happen for where a
developer didn't have all the resources
to them but we're gonna put our game on
one console and now I may put that game
on the 360 a couple times
next Jing was that one the ps4 PS 5 you
want it to be your platform or for more
developers I understand we will make
maximize our revenue and if you put it
on both you don't want to give them
excuses to not put their games on your
platform because oh I gotta do all these
multiple SKUs you making me jump through
all these hoops now what else I got I
got I got I got support your trash Xbox
one - I mean like what else do you want
from me
I just won't put my game on your
platform just be simple like everybody
else but yeah that's the kind of stuff
that you just don't want to hear from
your developers and I think it was a
good decision by them to say you know
what this Lockhart here
I knew it went well so the verb the
Burge interview in the confusion and
their lack of communication is also the
other reason why this Xbox division
isn't the best at doing stuff like this
because they I mean ok so the version of
you the guy asks the question ok so the
project's Carla is this one console is
it is it like three is it what what is
this and then feel even his answer was
begging and weird like well you know
work is focused on projects Carl in this
and I'm like I think from this i'ma put
out on Twitter I'm like is he saying
Lockhart doesn't exist but I can't tell
I just wish that they'd be more open
conversation like if you killed it just
say yo we messed up we backtracked like
we've been doing all gen but we promise
we know what we doin now
I mean like they keep confusing people
don't jump out there saying we gonna
have the most powerful car so and then
say people have the most powerful cons
we're gonna make you go to Windows oh
you ain't go to
I give it to King in the defense of
these guys like we have to admit that
these things are not made yet right so
and they don't know what Sony's doing
yet right so at the end of the day for
them to say we definitively have the
most powerful console when technically
the PlayStation 5 is still not finished
you know I'm saying like I kind of get
that to an extent but I've know where
you're going with verbage because
normally I would say most powerful
console and then it Kings to most
powerful console we've ever made and I
get that like I gotta get King in
because the chat is saying King needs to
throw people in the bushes they said
they said we need to hear from our King
so King the floor is yours they are
ready for your response to Lockhart rest
in peace or not all right so it just
went left
like I just I just listen there it just
got really ridiculous um all right guys
you do know something called research
and development right is a whole
division that's dedicated to this part
right we do also know that all this
speculation and all this crap that's
going on is what it is it's speculation
and crap now they're building this
console going all the way through a big
division a big corporation as Mike
Microsoft has multiple SKUs that they're
looking at and they're trying to figure
out what is the best way to get this to
the market and get the best out of it
so in doing so when you go to the
research and development you have a
different idea teams that's coming up
and one idea team they say hey we got
this Lockhard thing that we can get at
an entry point coming in and then
another research development team says
we have this anaconda which is the most
powerful thing that we can put out and
then they'll sitting there talking about
it so what we're getting is information
from people that's leaking stuff talking
about oh this is this is not fact this
is not anybody sat out there said
anything now as far as Phil talking
about scarlet he's not gonna give in to
the rhetoric of the speculation because
he can't but he also knows that this
research and development going on in the
background now as far as being accurate
when you're saying that this is gonna be
the most powerful system that we've made
yeah now do you do the Xbox with a
purist want to sit there and pump their
fists talk about it's gonna be
the most affinity system though the
strongest console okay that's great but
at the same time also remembered is that
the the weakest console right now is
performing the best alright so don't
don't don't get caught up in the power
narrative even though we want it because
we thought that and I'm talking from
Xbox and pointing we thought that we
lost the battle going in because we
would read the console we lost the
battle because we tried to force a
Kinect on people that didn't want it we
lowered the power ski we've resorted and
resource 10% of the power to go to a
Kinect that nobody wanted we wanted that
10% of the power to the system all right
so it's choices that was made that made
people lose the generation and that's
cool you're supposed to lose when you
mess up that's what's supposed to happen
right but going forward we're gonna see
what it turns out to be so rest in peace
Lockhart we don't even know if this rest
in peace Lockhart it might be like yo
that's on the back burner and like Forte
or slow-mo the same that X is a viable
sister back poof do not say that the ex
is not gonna be utilized in the front
yeah we also I'm gonna say this that
somebody made a comment about no
controller no dis little bat left behind
it won't be left behind when you have
the X cloud so when that's being said
that's accurate because not he will
carry over accessories have to carry
over right but when when when kognito
tells me stuff like he plugs his xbox
controller into his PC and it works that
way they're telling you that they're
trying to future-proof it with the
accessory so a lot of things we're
nervous right you've been beaten into a
corner you ever seen something at your
corner better notice we are not make the
wrong move you don't want the wrong move
to happen I feel you okay who killed
Lockhart for you can you know what I
think it is Carly
yeah I think it is that they realized
that Sony was gonna go in but I don't
think at the initial start they thought
the Sony was gonna aim for like a 400
price tag
they were gonna try to beat them at
price point and power but I think now
that they're gonna try to beat them up
there they're gonna beat them come in at
the same price point with their highs
with the Scarlett yeah and hopefully
beat them in power a just have the same
price because it's a lot different
scenarios than it was last gen addict I
think this right and I think with this
is where a part where the this is the
fun part fun
the speculation yeah not knowing did
this give us a time for us influence
influences and youtubers to sit there
and speculate and do what we do and be
absolutely completely wrong who killed
Lockhart I don't know because neither
you see but when somebody leaks out
something to say yo we got the beetle in
the corner
yeah like yo did you hear about the new
beetle controller right listen calm down
we don't know anything and what we're
doing right now is giving you our
opinion to my knowledge have they ever
came out openly they've never the only
got from them was the like last year's
e3 they said consoles too and then when
they said that then that's when all of
the leakage came out yo shout out the
others Inc who keep telling slow-mo to
be cool this is how far I am in his head
he hears me even when that dogs for
doubt man let me tell you something when
Brad Sam said that developers warn it's
exactly excited kill it don't don't we
don't want the developers know seriously
I mean we don't want you don't want
developers to to go in there and we're
gonna know that lockout right where that
Kinect 2.0 is yeah
it's gonna be like that sprinkling gift
with a dude that did the salt you don't
know but I mean with the developer said
that I'm like hey listen to developers
you don't want them to be you don't want
them to come in with this mindset of ugh
we got developed from okay that's gonna
turn into bitter and then before you
know there's not games coming out on
xbox like know your Sony you say hey you
know we got one platform on during you
know what it is like when addict was
gonna bust a gasket a minute ago right
and y'all just sitting there waiting get
King give me that ring they go in that
Xbox and maybe talk about PlayStation is
doing accident champions tripped on a
banana peel just stop it with all this
crap comes I'm listening to it it is
like people say oh the research and
development is bad yeah I don't go
inside a car dealership and say you know
what I'm just gonna get the top of the
line oh Corvette no I'm gonna say you're
maybe I might not need to go 200 miles
an hour let me see exactly what the
situation might call for if you don't
need to outshine somebody so much don't
blow out your pockets trying to prove
something to somebody that you'll need
to pull you just be better than the next
dude I can't you can't jump on Microsoft
for killing something they never
announce facts with the most logical Bob
you this other thing
we go back to talking how can you sit
like this my little banana peeler that's
why so do you know what why that might
be perfect that might be a perfect
analogy of the generations you know
Mike's awkward has had a decent amount
of clout going in from the 360 you know
how that that ex that that souped the
Mario Kart were you at the very finish
line and he throw them over then you get
plat right at the last minute they were
set up we said if right Brad use the
software hmm you forget Sony didn't have
crap Howard they had nothing - both had
the software going in they slipped on
that banana peel and Along Came digital
foundry that's well if you go okay we're
gonna go through this next
consul-general because we you do this
every console generation I mean like
everyone does I mean it says since the
days of you know the NES and SNES power
is always the first thing people talk
about because there's nothing else to
talk about unless unless you're wrapped
up on that and to be that way there's no
just I mean unless yeah and adding on
new content likely bombard us with all
these new Sony has put themselves in a
great situation with these new IPs like
horizon I don't know if there's gonna be
another blood-borne yeah gosu Kashima I
think it's because I think some of these
gonna be crossfire
I think last post is still gonna be on
his clout by then Microsoft they put
themselves in a decent situation
hopefully with these new studios I don't
think I think this is the last gin that
power is relevant that much like I think
it's gonna be relevant for like the
first six months you know the whole
thing is always about the mistakes that
these companies make in the beginning
and again like in King brought up what
we know the mistakes the Xbox made but
this isn't the first time that's
has been a accident champion the very
personal police station ran out of money
with the Dreamcast and they couldn't
they couldn't continue to compete that's
what I was lost at mine they can really
run the industry even force everyone I
use cartridges which of course so many
developers directly in Tucson these arms
like scope like square with Final
Fantasy 7
so like this isn't the first time that
like Sony has fallen into a position of
dominance and I don't believe in
accidents like that you still have to
capitalize on really do anything like
dating go tell Nintendo make cartridges
no no but they they still have to
execute and capitalize on supporting and
building relationships with these with
these developers like Sony when Sony
came around the block nobody one of the
[ __ ] was Sony excuse my language
nobody wanted to mess with Sony because
they were like who Sony you know is Lu
Tendo and Sega at the time and Sony had
to build those relationships with those
developers and even though Nintendo made
mistakes they still have to capitalize I
don't I don't think it's all your
competition just that's not so nice go
left
I'm not saying it's their fault about
what I'm saying they didn't do anything
to create that situation happening I'm
give you an analogy just real quick
right you have you a champion right you
go in the ring and the guy comes in and
he's ready to fight and you throw a
punch you twist your ankle you go down
and he can't run now you are the floor
did he earn that belt because he did he
was there he was present twist your
ankle and you went down and they counted
you out you feel that he earned that
even he got the belt off the guy
breaking his ankle he still got oh you
know you're
yes Yuta Yuta champ you threw the punch
and you twist your ankle and you went
down and you couldn't get up and they
counted you out and that guy is standing
there he trained he came in shape he was
ready to go but you went out on your own
ankle
he's gotta still maintain ankles over
here there is a king saying that no he's
like III secretly do that in the morning
yeah yeah yeah but that's where I saw
that from it was like little giants but
it was like that little kid he was like
12 years old but he had he was like the
size of a high school and his father was
like yeah man we train every morning I
see further milk it's the bus it is
definitely got all Spitfire man listen
this being the most fire though my fires
blue yeah here's your fire right
right there would you say my fire made
that fraud alert I cannot agree with all
you guys I think that at the end of day
one skew is probably the best route you
know I'm saying then it's like like
practicing if the devs are telling you
fam we want we're gonna develop for the
Lockhart and just let you know that
there are common denominator that's
where we going with our resources and
Microsoft and himself are not happy that
shows to me they want to showcase the
power of an economy you guys show that
it's a jump so that when I hear that
kind of talk
I'm super excited and like I forgot who
said I think was for tape at the end of
the game the X is still a viable
platform right yeah if sense becomes the
new Lockhart you know I'm saying and if
you put a nice little price reduction it
you literally have the two SKUs that you
were gonna engage meeting exactly I'm
Vince yeah let's let's just talk about
one thing like King when he said the
thing about tripping and falling and
people winning because of it that stick
you with me a lot but ultimately he's
right because Microsoft will see in the
next generation if Microsoft doesn't do
this one thing they'll do it they'll
slip it fall over again some people
don't know that the first year of Xbox
one and ps4 being out Microsoft led in
software even knowing Sony was still
leading at consoles that's because
Microsoft did what had third party deals
that they still foster from the 360
right what happened that next year all
the third party developers went over to
say yeah and I've always said that from
a part cuz I'm about to have to leave
like exclusives matter I think that's
the key point to picking up your console
but one of those consoles are picked up
third parties what keeps people know you
know y'all y'all are missing what really
went what happened mmm-hmm Sony launched
in more regions yes they did right in
the mini reasons I gotta go you guys
besides Brian I'm joking Xbox was only
in like 11 regions at first there was
more that they were in 21 countries but
PlayStation launched in 49 countries yes
see that's the part that people don't
get and when they made the false
narrative of it being a shortage it was
a shortage because they say you know
what we're gonna set up I don't care if
we're sending a hundred thousand here we
sent him 50 thousand here we're gonna
show lines of people waiting on fighting
to get this thing this machine
Microsoft's strategy in that area was
flawed right what Sony did and they
capitalized on the fact that they didn't
have the software at that point in time
but they were able to get that hard way
and they start establishing the pipeline
once you establish a pipeline someplace
it's very easy for you to get that from
point A to point B because you already
did it the first time and then it
becomes a little bit more easy at a
second time so then when they're getting
the shipments out we got a million right
now we split it up and we're send these
here fifty thousand go to these guys
again another fifty thousand goes which
it won was really positive and fighting
for us oh we wanna send two hundred
thousand here Microsoft made a tactical
error and they pick of regions where
they were strong in Sony instead of
doing where they were strong in they
attacked regions where they were
weakened and he took over Microsoft's
are a crowd
so if plus $100 cheaper that's all just
about Hyundai achieving okay you're more
powerful $100 cheaper also bounce moves
has a good point which as well the
problem is the Kinect was forced on
everyone and I think in some of the
regions that they didn't launch in is
because
didn't have the language altogether
language yeah so that that connect was
just a man well that's the one thing I
was gonna ask you King do you I always
wondered this do you think when Sony
came out and gave that date Microsoft
didn't want to be behind that far so
they were only a week behind him with
the release date right do you think that
that release date was only picked
because Sony picked they're so early
they didn't want to come out that far
behind them they wanted to like race
them neck to neck but that's why they
didn't have the systems to put
everywhere like they wanted to okay I
might answer this in two parts right why
did the 360 beat the PlayStation 3 came
out of here early thank you now that was
11 million Lee before plays a new tech
people daddy you don't think they know
that in that company they know that
they're going up against a very
formidable foe and we can't allow them
to have a lead way so I honestly believe
that that connect was an albatross
around a neck I knew that that let
language remember to use her arm user
interface it was broken in the beginning
like we yeah the stuff he was wasn't
implemented properly
we got blades and stuff changed over a
period of time it got to where it's at
now but I don't think they were ready as
far as the interface I don't think they
was ready as far as the language with
that connect because remember you was
able to talk to you connect it with the
Kinect 2.0 you was able to do all this
magical stuff with it could see your
infrared body between the bushes
albatross around a neck instead of
implementing it later instead of
bringing it out later and let the the
the people Alucard the thing they forced
it on them and I thought I think that
was a detriment because I think that
also messed up the user interface okay
they also didn't launch with the correct
development tools for No
anyways you know they were they were
still using DirectX 9 or something or I
forget what DirectX they were using but
it wasn't even the DirectX they were
supposed to be using or what they had in
plan for the Xbox one when it launched
you had to start with this yeah I always
oh it did that when I when I got my PS I
got both day one and I always looked but
I looked at ps4 the interface was clean
yes everything works it was said when I
got it it was snappy and when I got to
the next box I was waiting for space
alone so I always thought that I was
like this system yes they got it out but
it wasn't ready I had a crime basically
as 360 fans we looked at any like member
the consensus with the OS at the time
was there's a step back yeah we like you
guys had the og OS with 360 lip all you
had to do was copy paste and you would
have been fine no we had regressions
with party chat the Snap feature didn't
remember the tool TV heavy focus you
know I'm safe Stevie too much but end of
the day just real quick with the whole
thing I like what they're doing with it
I like that it's a single unified
message and I'm saying with the Scarlet
woman with the Annika
so we believe oh we believe from what is
speculated and what well I want a shower
brass sands he made a good point he said
another thing that they're saying is the
initial tests with arm X cloud have been
so good and above their expectation at
this stage because we know we still
haven't got a proper trials yet he's her
dad day our heckle or five GL o58
perfectly right but what they're saying
is they're like yo they're so impressed
with the tech that they're saying this
could be their entry-level model into
people for the next gen that just wanna
you don't wanna tell you some just
because you didn't make it to e3 and I
told you use one missile see you say you
coming next year yes all right I'm a
whole journeys to the
cheese box right yes for your knees if
you know baby if you don't make it I'm a
male of box to your housing project
gameplay shout out to Bill still the
wall I'm going to tell you guys because
you know I watch a little stupid
comments that's under my video that's at
25,000 views right now but I'm telling
you because boom is right there as
gamers
I played other stuff certain things you
want to be blown away by right I was
blown away yeah that this thing is
finally being utilized
yes cellphone like we paid a thousand
dollars for these things
mmm-hmm have taken it as stronger than
yo-yo your switch please some of this
tech is stronger than the 360 it's not
good at a Playstation yes right and it's
never been utilized thanks when I saw
that I said my phone is it true next
year I'm going to be doing raids from e3
I'm just controlling I'm out and you out
it listen people again I'm not gonna
we're not going to talk about other
people's experiences right we could just
talk for what we played what we
experienced and I'm telling y'all right
now like I said for what me and King
touched it was because listen I'm gonna
be real with y'all brat like I am the
most skeptical person when people
bloviate me and King have been through
it all in 3do era trip Hawkins m2 I've
been there with you guys I get it
through all the marketing speak and oh
it's good this integral clay remember
x-band
I remember bein cartridge on Genesis I
bet I know what latency is you know I'm
saying and I'm the biggest person who
say yeah it's gonna be okay
but it is and I'm gonna test it I'm a
mover I'm on trial trying to break this
thing to see if I can catch the floor
yeah I do that's gonna come in and try
to really push it technically right and
get away with and to have this thing in
my hand and I'm playing Halo 5 60 frames
per second
yes it was 720p you couldn't tell me
with 720p without gorgeous that salad
samsung galaxy screen look and the
movements precise stopping on a dime no
delay I'm telling you right now again
yes you can say it's a controlled
environment to an extent yes we have to
test that on our homes yes we have what
4G I get all that I will give you guys
that but to have such a strong initial
impression like what King is saying what
boom experience well it's mind-blowing
and it makes you walk away like yo they
may have won so if they're that impress
this early and saying that this would be
an entry level point for the next
generation for people would possibly do
that game passed ultimate subscription
being part of it that's a big deal
that's it do I you know I I do agree
with you guys to a certain extent I
haven't experienced the way you guys did
at e3 but I think they see the potential
in this especially in countries that
have a far better network infrastructure
than we do like South Korea like Japan
they have Azure data centers they have
two in Japan they have them also in
Korea and I think that's where we
started to get some of that talk from
Phil about hey you know I'm looking at
potentially acquiring a Japanese
developer or setting up our own studio
because typically really the kind of
games that are first party that Xbox has
are at the kind of games that the
Japanese gravitate to and and but then
you got stuff like it was that crisis X
game that they show the e3 that's like
the most hottest game in South Korea
like you
this is giving them a new way of trying
to get into a market that they've been
traditionally shut out of in Japan in
Asia you're not really going to be
crucial for them it's good I think
that's a really good thing although over
here I think for us it's still always
gonna be a secondary mess a secondary
method of playing games
so always because you know everyone's
moving the same way how King talked
about how he's got like you know what
$80,000 PC did man like but he still
want that console experience is sitting
on his couch or playing his games I'm
the same way
like I haven't built the PC because I
just like sitting in my computer chair
and playing games
I tried actually tried that actually
moved my Xbox and Playstation into my
work my homework office and for a while
was cool back just like I prefer my my
4k HDR 60-inch TV and sitting on my
couch and I had to move it all back so
there's some people that's just the way
they are and I think even said this with
with enrique on breath last week that
you know like they're really trying
capture that mobile market to those
those the 51 percent of all total
revenue out there for gaming revenue
comes from mobile and then Sony's seeing
that and they be kind of rubbing their
hands together
Microsoft scene and they were over there
hands together but like these people
don't really they don't really always
gravitate to kind of games that we love
right so I think they're gonna also
start letting to come out with gears pop
you know they want to get something
that's going to get people who will play
on the go I play I play a lot of stuff
when I'm waiting on line and I'm doing
things exactly if I can stand on line
like a being away with my forte I'm just
thinking about doing my destiny grind
stuff that I hate doing you know say
just remotely and still real Spencer's
playing that's they're telling me like
he's yeah what did your panties play
he's a big destiny fan I'm saying he's
doing that on that's cool I like that
type of stuff excited to be a half
your achievements all that Xbox Live
integrated you know feature set
continuing after the home console and I
agree with slow this is not for
everybody like there's people just don't
want that dedicated console experience
that's not going anywhere that will
always be the number one way to play but
to have this option is gonna be exciting
for a lot of gamers that's what I got
shadow Jabari to play PlayStation nation
in the bill and ISIL stuff I see you
let's move right on cuz we got to get
out of here soon man um attic topic we
had a demise of III and then we were
talking about destiny real quick so real
quick but it basically what attic was
saying was on obviously the Sony lack of
presence you know and Activision we you
know we never a gaping hole so his
concern is that is this are we coming to
the final stages of III you know I'm
saying what do we think about it so uh
let's get braaap in there what you think
a week what we're getting towards the
end now that these guys are you know not
not part of the festivities like we have
this conversation for for the last
couple years ever since you know EA
decided to kind of walk off the campus
if you will and do their own thing plus
they catch strokes in the heat in the
Sun people out EA for trying to kill
people yeah I've admitted a three but
yeah we we asked this question we had
Matt piscatella on from MPD oh listen to
the show Rachel thank you and we asked
Matt that question you know like what's
going on with e3 he's like you know it's
it's kind of in this unique place now
where it's not really in a trade show
the way it used to be but it's also not
really you know like a fan festival
either it's kind of like a combination
of the two and he it sounded like two
trying to figure out what they want to
be next and you know we said to Matt we
asked Matt's today just the Sony need to
be at e3 and do you think they'll be at
e3 next year and he's like you know
that's 5050 he thinks that in today's a
day
Dave age with influencers and I'm gonna
paraphrase some of the stuff he was
saying here but more or less he was
saying like you know they cannot they
could be okay with you know not going a
three because of things like YouTube
things you know social media events like
PSX when they have a little more
all the messaging well you Sara Lee
don't have to use III anymore to get the
message out there and so I thought that
was kind of interesting and which we
leave I think the you know III and in a
kind of interesting you know situation
where if it's not really going to be a
traditional trade show you know what is
it gonna be then you know they're gonna
be more like a pax he does think that
they need to maybe make it tour I think
his his thing was if he was head of the
SA he would make it more like a Gamescom
we have like the day for you know the
press and for the for the industry and
then the next three days would be off of
the fans and that may be that may make
more sense you know for e3 but I did ask
my say do you think that he that they
should move the the venue he's like
absolutely he's like LA is just a pain
about to get around and maybe moving it
around a different areas might be
beneficial to into the to the event so
I'm LA as a pain in the butt to get
around I actually think everything is
strategically placed nice but you so you
like he prefer that la no I I wanted to
go all over okay you know I don't want
to finish Brett yeah um all right being
going there right and the first year I
went it was closed off to the public
okay and knowing that it when it was
just a trade show and you would go in
and it was just media and you were able
to sit down get to interviews and it
seemed like productivity was that a high
but remember we had a transition year so
the fact that Sony took office because
one they had nothing to show all I can
do is actually hurt they self um so they
said you know we're not gonna waste the
money
look at these dudes you know say
whatever and people thought they was
gonna put out something during the show
they did I don't think the fact I want
to watch and hit that like button y'all
shower on just go come on it they're
like have a good time y'all country you
came I don't think that Sony not being
there means is the death of you three
and a lot of their friends will say that
you know I didn't care for III this year
of course you didn't because your people
wasn't
the people you buy your burgers from
didn't have no meat for you that we
shout out to your vegan meal Oh
for those brothers that was on the
markets off camp so it was brutal
live and banging like I'm gonna keep it
real with you wasn't there you you were
looking through your TV screen it was
enough for you to see you're gonna feel
like it's a death or something if it's
nothing for you to view a lot of people
that go to Netflix and be like
definitely a kid you need a shin kick in
your knees for that slam bar let's
boogie down so you to certain eases in
the box oh you're welcome next year to
come out and hang out with the Lords in
Cali and eat three and actually Sita in
touch because Nintendo was represented
on that floor sir all right so um when
we're out there Nintendo has a huge
presence people will go in there it
changes like I would love like you said
for it to be one day for just media
press and and get in there get your
interview get get your stuff in right it
would right now it turns into a whole
free fall and what you notice now is now
these guys got to get up at seven
o'clock in a guy morning it there to get
an interview with death early in the
morning instead of having a whole day to
plan out your date getting all your
interview rooms and during the week year
now our early before the show starts and
when the show floor starts here comes
these hungry people and it turns to
something different
first it will never be a pax if you ever
been to pax pax is a beautiful
cornucopia of gaming yeah right
literally you're touching there's no
is that just ending on it's getting it
it's there isn't it sucks crap I don't
own a min there don't the Gaul kognito
get his first down don't make the
mistake I did okay but packs it will
never be a packs because packs has a
formula that is set up for gamers right
it is really made for you'd and it
cultivated that over a period of time
this III the way they switched it over
now they get they have to get they foot
and like you said they're in a position
trying to figure out what they want to
be and I don't think they understand
that yet but if they keep taking advice
from you guys can be something special
no doubt Lords forte and slow-mo slow-mo
in so what are you feeling about III is
a dying it's just right it's not dying
it's a I think the whole well you know
EP was different this year or the it
wasn't as I wasn't as high past as I
usually am I mean look it's it's not
just because Sony wasn't there it's the
end of the chain and so like these
companies are holding things back there
there Sonny isn't there because they
it's not like they're not working on
games they're working on games we're
gonna games for ps5 and when they show
those games they don't want to show you
PS five footage on games without
actually announcing that PS five yet so
and I also believe Xbox hat games
because you know each other stuff back
they got X though nineteen coming out
later this year and just III next year
so they're gonna I think III next year
is gonna be amazing because you got two
big platform boulders to a showing or
announcing their their new consoles is
showing you a ton of games to try to get
people to for the later that year to go
ahead and purchase that console so it's
gonna be it's gonna be high five now I
will tell you something that I've said
I've been an advocate for for a long
time and that I think the way these I
think III is great and all these
conferences are great but I don't like
how these platform holders hold back
stuff just for that I think that
whenever a game has it is ready to be
shown you should just show it yeah you
should you should show it like the wait
Nintendo
shows that stuff at the Rex you should
show it they have inside Xbox in this
book it's a bore fest every time it
comes out why don't you show like the
new your theories next game they're
coming out net that announced these
games when they're ready to be announced
and then you don't have to go to a
developer like hey are you are you ready
for III yet no no look you ready you be
ready when you're ready you know we and
then we could drop that at like July
inside Xbox fax just real quick slow I
told him a problem we see and we had
shout out to the Xbox to we had on last
week is that it feels like there has
been an internal memo since the
scalebound situation that they are not
going to show stuff that is not ready
second thing Mon Amie with the ten
dollar super chat next gen III 2020 mods
gaming is coming for sure mom ma'am are
you coming to the compound to the
compound are you guys the house less
lords of gaming dotnet finest tech news
my man mods gamers so look J bar with
shout out to the aisle or pod good
shoulder Yoshi little brother we missed
you on the PlayStation journey for that
slope bro we gotta bring you some JJ I
don't win at you with the knees in the
box
you chose to just say good like you been
in I wanted to read that he said I'll be
a nice man will be okay or you feel like
it just because of the holding back and
people just gearing up for next year
next year gonna be late I think it's
always gonna be okay and I think I think
one one you have phil spencer who's also
on the board with the esa in the esa
holds e3 and Phil is gonna make sure
that Xbox is always well
they're there they're never gonna stop
going there I think Sony's definitely
gonna be back next year I just like my
whole part about I think that they don't
really necessarily need to hold all
their announcements in their big reveals
just for the conferences like III I
think they should switch it up and
really show those things when they're
ready to be shown if that's November if
that's August if that's February so be
it but just you can still show sure that
stuff at e3 as well you show a little
bit more content but still I think in
the in 2019 in the age of the internet
you don't need to hold everything back
just for the conferences I agree louis
xiv is it dying is just a rat for III
know and i think III I think because I
think we're gonna get a whole nother
breath of fresh air when next year comes
out I think I'd in from these systems by
itself will do that that's all the
reason I didn't go this year I was like
man why would I go I said it was nice to
go this year you try to pay that ticket
though I already told my wife I was like
next year gotta be ere gotta be this is
you brap Fonzarelli but tell me right
now I know my wife already my wife
already knows all right put the start
planning to see all right Brett you know
no refunds I will tell that to but honey
once I once I put in its eye I told my
wife she'd been willing to go to San
Diego comic-con for like the last couple
of years so I already I already told her
I was like well I'll go to Eve we go to
eat if I go to e3 we'll go to San Diego
Comicon next year so we are ready we're
already saving up for that so that's
gonna be that's gonna be pretty much set
up to you on the bride I can't go on the
glue I work for again so I work against
that I already leave
one like for a whole week to go to our
own little pattern we have our little
thing with the developers and stuff for
a week so me to do that twice in one
year and she'd not get anything out of
it yes so I think it's still gonna be
relevant I just think that uh next year
is gonna be incredible after that it
just really just comes down to the venue
Microsoft hasn't been inside of the
actual III arena for the last two or
three years now
yeah Nintendo has been gone forever and
in freaking EA is off in the bushes in
Hollywood so if they if it ain't die by
now it's not gonna die within the next
few years just because everybody's gonna
be back under the same roof for the most
part in the same area this this is a
misnomer
this is the real quickly on the
Microsoft front they have their whole
Microsoft theater you know right alright
and that I mean to not use your own
place crazy right but they do use their
own place but then in the convention
hall there's an xbox whole section there
it's not as big is because they're using
that they want you to go over today join
bod a swag go over there they have a
whole beautiful section it's really nice
but Nintendo blew it out
every year these dudes
they are the main attraction phiiiy yes
fortnight move look like I heard that
they was all pictures of it I was like
you know what the pokémon's had two
separate giant it was so crazy I said
you know I'm just gonna go to the
Nintendo section for the for the
third-party stuff and now you're like an
hour and two just to be on that line
like that was crazy and I was in there
with the industry media section in that
line was still in Nintendo completely
dominates on the floor it's yeah listen
enough for tonight what you're talking
about is what pub G was lashing last
year yeah
what pub G did that hundred man thing
for tonight did it this year and the
difference what for tonight is they
remember they have character
so the characters was represented you're
seeing the videos that I'm about to post
this week um do you think the characters
was larger than life it was it was it
was very nice they put their money what
they made and put it on the floor
no absolutely represent we're gonna
offer um look we can't allow you know
Sony's president's lack of presence and
Activision lack of president he
definitely hurt on that side so Nintendo
definitely showed out like we know new
systems are coming right mMmmm no
guarantee so do you gonna have to come
back like cuz my thing is let's just say
they'd be like you know what that's fine
that bread we just do this reveal on a
piece we be good like I wouldn't put it
past them with Sony say you know like
again I should they be there yes it's a
strong possibility they be there yes all
I'm saying is also a strong possibility
my in my opinion they sit they say to
himself hey you don't necessarily have
to be on that bright so I foresee in
February all they shocked us yeah
even I thought they would be petty and
trying to give us that Last of Us
announcement right right right after my
Castro come everybody all by yourself
just did and they really service that
with this annex I mean this is the right
in his head oh you stayed quiet while we
do up so they say Dave too much money
they give no hush money they told them
we give you bad service if you don't
shut up
oh the other thing is what I think grab
polluted too with his shout out to Matt
Chris can tell you guys had them on
broadcast fantastic show by the way um
it reference to we andromus possibly rap
of a venue change after so much that to
increase said that that was kind of
going around III that there could be a
venue change and there's actually better
the ESA Phil Spencer on the board ESA
internally and there was an article in
Vanity Fair about this the place
internally is a mess and they're all DC
they fire their executive the executive
director of the yesterday cuz apparently
he was not a nice guy what for there's a
lot of high turnover I mean people we're
not happy working for this guy
don't play favors with snap we're full
spread try to come out and say hey is
everything okay but he had come on yes
they eventually fired him real quick
fire topic cuz we gotta get out of here
quick fire which would be the destiny
thing we know about our mistake which is
you know we know about the the free to
play stuff no big war free to play with
shadow key and then you know maybe but
King I'm doing to this year topic where
you at with this wish old situation with
Destiny's future have a destiny play but
I'm not even looking see how many hours
I put in as a person who's bought and
purchased every piece of content that
these guys have brought out for these
dudes to smack me in my mouth and the
turn around and say oh you know like
this I just wanted to bring it to the
floor cuz all these dudes play destiny
here mmm-hmm I want to bring it to the
floor how you like being smacked in the
mouth telling you yeah efforts and your
dollars really don't count going forward
because we won't give it out to the new
dudes for free alright let's get some
clarity before tape
please explain about the new light
system and how they probably don't have
access to everything but right so damn
brother
so the free-to-play version of this game
is like you said destiny is still
destiny is not-it's not a separate game
the only difference is everything that
is destiny outside of the raid for
Forsaken this the raid and the the
strikes for the shadow key are walled
off it's like a wall guard you can't do
none of that stuff unless you buy the
DLC for those things you'll go you can
still go to all of the destinations you
can still go to all the patrol missions
for every planet on the game even the
one for shadow key but you can't do any
of the endgame activity for forsaken or
anything for shout keep going forward
PvP will be free for everybody
umm gambit and get B Prime free for
everybody but you you will be able to
still hit the max power cap in the game
um but the only difference like I said
you won't be able to play in those
higher tier activities when the new DLC
drops if you want that stuff you just
have to pay for forsaken which they
already said will be at a heavily
discounted price by the time it comes
out they didn't explode what it would be
yet and then if you buy for say you buy
shadow keep it gives you pretty much all
the rest of it it didn't you're
basically up to date with destiny going
forward mmm alright so what about two
kings question for today the future now
cuz he's saying part of what he's also
saying in reference to because they got
this model and it seems like they're
gonna be adding on things you know
shadow keep now it bring him back to
moon you bring them back these these
spaces that we had almost like a
continuous world does this now hamper
destiny Drees development that maybe
they say hey if they have someone
success with this free to pay model in
its new light that they push back d3 or
don't do d3 at all uh me me personally i
don't if they do a d3 they do with III
if they don't they don't I mean I'm more
out me person
I believe the engine is agile enough
even the engine can be changed and they
can still keep the base of what destiny
is they could change everything in the
game and still keep the fundamentals of
what the game is now okay I think I
think if they want to capture a wider
audience like people that were burned or
destiny in the first place right you
probably want to put another number on
it because then that instead that
basically speaks to people like this is
something new where destiny if you just
say destiny - like shadow keep or that's
you - whatever people still feel like
they have like yeah yeah they still
funny thing I play catch-up now this
whole yo new light situation I don't
know how that's gonna play out it's
gonna bring a lot of people back into
the fold
people that not probably never even
played destiny you're gonna try it
because it's gonna be free everywhere so
ultimately it really just comes down to
I think they're gonna look at the
numbers over the course of the next year
mm-hmm and I think is what's gonna
happen is destiny they're working on
whatever that next big thing is right
maybe it's whatever the code name is I
don't know if they're gonna call it
destiny 3 or whatever me personally I
don't want to change the game over again
I don't want to have a destiny theory I
just want them to continue destiny for
what it is if anything when the next
version comes out just drop the number
drop a number and say destiny whatever
subplot this blah blah blah blah blah
nothing therefore no but but ultimately
this really just comes out to just that
I don't think it's a bad thing I just
think they want to get more people back
into the the grinding mill as we like to
speak in destiny um but it'd be free I
feel you King I feel you a lot because I
do feel away about it cuz we me person I
bought destiny all three platforms all
the DLC I owned it everywhere I own and
I'm gonna do and shadow keep I'll buy
everywhere again because they already
said you gotta buy shadow key to be able
to play the new content so I'm gonna buy
it on three different platforms like a
place that's brought save across all
three of them but the experience that
I've got over five years of this game
the five or six hundred dollars I gave
them for this game over the course of
five years
I don't even think about that no more
but you feel a resentment like you said
no I don't to move forward for that way
right how do you feel how do you feel
the guy with no wallet comes and jumps
and playground the crime with you dude
have you paid forget about it
you got no wallet guy jumped in and was
like yo will be gonna do the strike be
banking all your moves be messing up
your game man Guardian 44 way man I feel
like this will breed more life into the
game I'm sorry you have it Elaine
Griffin look I don't have this problem
as much on constable and I was gonna pee
in cocking I can literally attest to
this crucible on PC is oh my it's like a
bunch you to a certain once you get to a
certain tier you're playing just the
sweatiest of the sweatiest people if I
do I'm sorry I used to I used to like on
console I'm good but and I'm at the top
there's so many good there's so many
gonna be it sweaty of the sweatiest oh
and what's it take mat long to find
matchmaking yes I'm saying it's a it's a
here's the thing - like we gotta also
stock this since they announced explain
to means the hole basically the top
percentile the guys that normally go to
the lighthouse the the eSport kind of
guy to God okay the guys that are you
I go into a game with my friend and he
doesn't even play the game but he don't
want to play with me because I'm playing
in an echelon of people that know they
don't want to ever turn it out they just
want to keep it super hard all the time
yeah that's what destiny or PC is it's
like ridiculous like I said it's not as
bad on console because there's so many
more people but just imagine what this
infusion of new people is gonna bring it
to the game I'm sorry I like this little
people to Guardians when they first come
in what are blueberries little numbers
above people's heads that I can't that
can't do yet that that to me is that's
when I enjoy to gain the most because I
know more people are coming into the
game versus recycling the same 30,000
people every day only these one negative
to that forty all and blueberries not
knowing how to do a heroic public event
we lived through that already I'll live
I'll live through that small detail to
be able to not sweat in a crucible every
ten minutes we gotta say with the
announcement of shadow keep it really
was the first time destinies active user
base is over 1 million shot in my
article wrote in a long time we get
slow-mo because he's the division
borderlands guy
vision into like a month I started my
own my own YouTube channel now I got one
video I write slobo I got my first video
out just like a conduction already
but my next video that should be coming
out tomorrow actually is and what's
wrong with the Division two
so I'm actually coming from you Wow and
getting a little deep one on you be
soften master so look at what the shots
I don't you know you I'm the same can
with you right now
wow that's big but now but in regards to
this topic so like when Connie and when
you sent me the question like I was like
hmm I thought I actually took this as we
are we talking about like destiny to
becoming a free to play game period
right or would they continue to do
sequels destiny 3 4 or 5 6 and so like
before to get to King's opinion about
him being a little a little upset that
people get to play it for free you also
got to look at the fact that you got to
play it at launch
you got to play for this deal seeing new
content right when they release whereas
these people are playing it well well
well afterwards so yeah they may be
getting it for free but they didn't get
like me going to play and I'm and I
played some DLC after the fact me
playing it when no one else was playing
and not really having a lot of people to
collect the try that content with me and
meet people when I did play it with
people they already a play through it
and I say they have the same excitement
right I had it's not the same so these
people are missing out on the experience
that you got to feel like the full the
full excitement of so we're still like
it's not the same experience anymore and
therefore you know they they're not
gonna get the same experience you got
you have nothing to worry about if I was
you I wouldn't be upset because it's
like I paid full price and I got it when
it was brand-new versus somebody coming
in and playing you know old content full
price I paid for part of it there's a
mushroom with fake anger okay now I
really care cuz I played the same
individuals every day anyway so you get
a blueberry and we vote them in and we
boot them out we make a key point to
never give it back to you slow is that
what
with new light that I like is one of the
things about destiny that's very
frustrating is if someone that is new
that hasn't let's say Enrique comes in
he's like yo I want to get down shot
right the law has always fundamentally
been with destiny is for a new guy has
to now got to do all the old story
content you got to do all this old
content just to get up and let's be
honest as an advanced testing player we
like we love rap to play but I don't
wanna have to do that old stuff level
and what I like with power surge
bounties and new light what they're
doing is saying yo he ain't gotta do the
campaign he do this one little mission
get a whole bunch of blues that'll put
him at 690 order whatever the current
light level is and he's ready to rock in
all activities but yes huge shades
because I know people are sound Eric
Jackson
oh yeah like people sit there and be
like okay I'll play but you're so far
ahead you know what's the incentive and
us as rush be real forth to do we really
like going through base campaign stuff
to bring your man's up like I love I
live destiny when people wouldn't play
if you didn't have a Gjallarhorn fact
Gjallarhorn up to me telling you ain't
got what's in the corner and you'll
touch nothing just look at us and try to
be quiet to get to something I actually
wanted to really discuss I'm excited to
talk about this all show real I think I
think that um and me being a warframe
player as well I'm deep into the loop
shooter genre like I play all of it
now that Bungie is no longer with
Activision they no longer have the
backing of this huge super rich
publisher and them being as big of a
developer as they are a hundred plus
employees and then some I think that
they really should try the warframe
model and the warframe model is it's all
all the contents free but the cosmedix
all the cool stuff I mean if you want to
get that that
Rhyno prime which is like the like the
regular Rhino warframe but better
spending that money to get that and
people the warframe community may be
smaller than a dusting community are you
talking about these people hardcore
gamers been playing this game for years
and and digital streams has never had a
money issue with their game never had a
problem with getting that game
additional content people are happy and
and and that community is is they're
really they really enjoy how the game
progresses because there's your streams
gives them what they want and they don't
mind putting money up to pay for certain
things I think that is the only really
loop shooter that is doesn't have the
backing of a major major publisher
that's out there getting it done
I think if Bungie really wants to be
successful you see the game going they
might want to Road that destiny content
into what destiny is now maybe drop that
to change the name a leg is B destiny
mm-hmm and then going continue going
forward you're getting like just you
know big content updates but this would
make people like I actually go to that
reverse I'd be like yeah you know I'm
gonna put some money in because I really
want this game to continue and I'm
enjoying the game that I'm playing and
you know it's helpful helping this
developer out you don't get your wish
phone so more on that yeah I think I get
your wish brap you wanna wrap this thing
up man well yet with it with this whole
you know for a free-to-play thing yeah
I'm down for I love I love the
free-to-play model think it's inviting
for more people I think more people in
the game is good it keeps the game going
and I think that yeah I suppose a
stabbed rat guys in DM do you think that
games is a service all games as a
service should go free-to-play model and
I forget what you guys I think most of
us kind of said yeah they should games
like you know see if these or anthem we
charge you 60 bucks the games relief
broken or don't have enough content I
think this is the way to go you know
give people the option to try it out for
free and if they want to buy into the
community they can I
I'm all for often so I think this is a
good thing for the that's right the game
path
which great coffee King I think on new
engine is gonna be fantastic
my gut still says d3 comes you know I'm
saying Lucas didn't okay
where's interested I still think cuz
Luke Smith kind of alluded when they
pressed him you know out that he's like
there you know we can't comment on the
next Network announced when I hear that
the to me that's like you still cooking
you know I'm saying
if this model works to your point King
David you never know this is this is why
I think it's dead
World of Warcraft World of Warcraft
right these news don't need to do
anything it will keep the same engine
and give you DLC over and over and over
again and and they went to a
free-to-play type of model to where they
were allowing people get the early
access to this stuff you know the
earlier stuff that nobody's buying that
nobody cares for you know us our elite
players right you know we'll get the new
DLC that comes down we have access to
that content and while we have the
blueberries don't have access to that
content and this is nothing new I was
just you know playing devil's advocate
going forward I understand that whatever
a company has to do to survive outside
of harming people do what you got to do
they're not harming anybody they
actually giving you inclusion so you
know shout out the fort a biggie one
more blueberries to beat up and I'm down
with him let's get on these biddies and
start shagging we need to take what any
easy put them in the box say it is
salute King he's an ability all they did
you in a building home all day
Odell no reason why I wanted okay is
that they I know ultimately their vision
is cross save cross progression and
cross I think I think they can do it
with this with the engine I think you're
out you there I don't think I think it's
already built in fundamentally - are
they just looking for this to switch to
hit it yeah listen I'm gonna lie but he
would you not would you turn down a next
generation engine destiny three doe
would you turn that down my god it is in
the PC if we can
this is over with my recent
controversies regarding cyberpunk 2077
as being offensive to specific groups of
people what do you feel is the right
course of action when these situations
occur in gaming the choices are a devs
have a moral responsibility and need to
be exposed if they cross the line be
gamers should judge for themselves and
vote with their wallet so see only group
offending should be able to catch
judgment or D I don't care as long as
that collector's edition is still as
that is Lord for teh Lord slow-mo back
slap and Lords brat we have mini Bradley
here without ever Jackson if you find
people find you for table if I do find
you sir oh man like you already said on
the infamous brat podcast man down every
Wednesday at 9:00 p.m. with these two
other fine fellas and the other two
people right here with us getting Forte
yeah twittering YouTube man that's me
content all the time man looping mind on
Twitter man putting up crazy means with
Pikachu and stuff my youtube channel
just because I'm bored it works
sometimes but uh man this was a pleasure
I really was looking forward to this
ever since the if I came and uh told you
I know you three four weeks ago man but
I really appreciate a man getting the
chance to hang with you guys and I can't
wait for III because I'll be shoulder to
shoulder with you guys there next year
that's gonna be living Lord slow-mo of
the black rubber man we're gonna pop you
five salute YouTube shadow man thank you
appreciate that yeah you guys can catch
me on Twitter and YouTube I can say that
now and YouTube the same name as slow-mo
back slap my YouTube channels will be a
little different I mean like you know
I'll take a hundred dollar version of EA
premiere on PC to get it seven days
early Wow Wow
no doubt Lord good to have you brother
wicked if I people find you what is
going on sir that's once a always a
pleasure to come on the IOP love you
guys keep up the great work man
seriously you guys are one of the best
operator thank you we're having me on
and yeah you can find find me on if you
go to youtube go to the basement video
arcade podcast you can find us there
we broadcast every Wednesday nights at
9:00 p.m. et no time and I've been known
to drop a rant or two
yeah had a great rent last night as a
matter of fact to our rent Xbox on Phil
Spencer's uh conference on Xbox Live not
being a platform for free speech and I
have Italian clowns and mr. boomstick I
want to pull me it's yes limo join us
towards the tail-end too and it was a
great conversation and two hours long a
lot of interesting comments in the
comment section be surprised or maybe
not surprised but please check that was
a good one so gentlemen thank you again
though always a pleasure
absolutely please yeah check out the
basement radio arcade podcast those are
our brothers man love that show and like
I said I told slow morning
I told rap when you guys added when you
added those two I really felt it take
the show to the next level of job before
and now it's like extra dynamic that's
the tow Maxis yes that's a GI Joe
paddling going on right there that I
love but um yeah salute the Brat Pack
has please watch those brothers really
good every Jackson be money to crew you
know I'm saying we have to show love to
you guys thank you supported us as well
so salute on that Lord King with all the
smoke today where can I find people find
you what's going on Kos pain okay for
those who didn't know if the others have
at the early in the show you know I
gotta say alright p2 two statues that
gasp buckled in the the group the
distress of my my shelving oh it was a
Wonder Woman it was Batman was nine
hundred dollars worth
alright so I just reached out to
somebody to see if they can actually
repair I know there's a fabric cake for
the Batman so that cape on the Batman
was a heavy resin
came so that is it's broke Wonder
Woman's hair is all messed up so what
I'm gonna do right now is I'm gonna get
the table I'm gonna lay out the pieces
and I'm gonna take pictures and I'll
send it to the guys see if you can
actually repair it if you fix it if not
then you know they're gonna go into the
bushes and now probably have to order
mom they were part of the original Holy
Trinity which is Batman
in Superman and the order that you want
to choose the shoe but I also have the
second Holy Trinity that's in boxes
that's gonna be unboxed on so I'm gonna
try to gather my thoughts get that
together because I was distraught this
morning laughing trust me when I tell
you this nobody wants to go inside they
little secret area and find out it's you
know something wrong you know Rob to
something yeah that's the worst feeling
bro we don't we know effort you put with
them statue so never hit me feels it too
bro
so but um this week I got something like
I told y'all if y'all watch the last
video I gave you a hint on what's the
next video gonna be and I'm trust me for
all you guys that like cosplay that uh
they're like tights so she could be seen
so she come back I can't wait I already
bill you cook it up the production is
lit shout out to attic I know he's doing
this thing at work we'll be back shout
to saw he will be back next week and you
already know shut loss gaming dotnet man
guys putting out tremendous articles
please check that out when you get a
chance out to the stream team MJ the
boys got a good one out there scary game
here's the ladders playing scary games
please watch that oh no with that yo-yo
he's the funniest brought think we found
MJ's the boss slaying him streaming
scary gazing no no no tears of my eyes I
had to watch it twice is the funniest
scary game streamer I have ever seen it
is here because he is literally
terrified this is why I was trying to
Enrique to do that because every K is
the same way the scary game every
texture I played Metro Exodus I got
scared
no I'm serious man okay then you don't
want to see the video to he playing
without word
something that we had got the key for
later all layers of fear oh yeah my
daughter's I watched my daughter played
and I was like nope
ya know my 14 year old was playing that
yesterday and I was like as I know I
just kept walking by going through
puzzles and stuff I'm like man crota you
should scare me listen Megatron I do
apologize the compound will be closer
next year and you know I do want to
spend time with my brother
I definitely missed you much holy shoot
out to the stream teens now those got
some stuff coming we already know and of
course like I said Laura you don't
kognito lordy bunches the last word you
already know Friday just catch that one
that is updated we talking about the
shadow keep stuff we're talking about
everything that's going on with transmog
and destiny Wow trance mom everybody
wanted that can't believe it's coming so
you already know what that is and you
know hit that like subscribe all that
good stuff went over but salute to
everybody today everybody enjoy your
Sunday and we out of here please